so at about 10 o'clock today there's
going to be a house vote again for Kevin
McCarthy he's lost 12 times it's quite
pathetic he's arguing he is going to win
when they come back we will see because
apparently there's at least five people
not including bobert who are like never
gonna vote for him sorry it's not going
to happen but if some Democrats don't
show up then the vote threshold goes
down he might actually be able to win
even if they don't get the freedom
caucus individuals who are holding out
but 14 other Republicans already flipped
but that's not the biggest news we're
gonna have some breaking news in into a
certain degree pertaining to Andrew Tate
there's a bunch of news coming out now
they're seizing more of his property and
we're hearing there will be uh we have
we have a potential statement from
victims I don't want to say too much so
just uh well bear with me on this one
and then we've got some other really
crazy stories in in cultural spaces that
I want to talk about about one the story
I saw the other day I think was James
Lindsay who posted it in cells are
becoming trans not because they're
gender dysphoric but because they they
they hold this ideology and I don't know
I don't know to what degree all of this
all of them feel this way but apparently
there are some guys that think women
have it so much better and their small
effeminate men that they're better off
transitioning for social benefits even
though they're not really gender
dysphoric or anything like that it's a
really interesting story and then we'll
talk about uh what was it Ashley
Babbitt's mom got arrested is that what
happened outside Margaret Taylor Green's
yelling about it yeah so we'll get in
all that stuff plus more before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
that join us button and you'll get
access to a massive library of members
only unsegmented unsen censored
uncensored segments from this show uh as
I mentioned not family friendly good fun
and it'll be uh generally supporting our
work because we enter this new year we
had a lot of big projects planned coffee
Shop's going to be really fun we're
gonna be launching a new skateboarding
show and just generally building culture
as well as trying to expand I should say
working to expand our news offerings so
with the new studio launching we're
going to be playing around with like a
Morning Show format I don't I don't know
if the live format in the mornings is
going to is going to persist what may
actually happen is just working in the
morning and doing more shorter segments
or something I'm playing around with it
we'll see how it works but the idea is
to produce more do more work while
freeing up more time in the middle of
the day to do the cultural stuff we want
to expand so with that being said smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us today to talk about this and
more is Eliza blue hi who are you my
name is Eliza I'm a Survivor advocate
for those affected by human trafficking
and I am also a survivor of human
trafficking right on so thank you for
having me back by the way absolutely
this is excited to be here you've been
on before yes so two years ago this
month actually oh cool right now yeah
well we have a lot to talk about yes and
I want to save it because we got some
big news so thanks for hanging out we
also got Luke chilling hey guys my name
is Lou kardowski if we are change.org
and I just wanted to remind everyone
that if you need violence to enforce
your ideas your ideas are worthless
that's exactly what it says on my shirt
and I think the last two to three years
definitely proved that if you agree with
this larger message get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com that's the
way you could support me for being here
because you do that's why I'm here thank
you again so much for having me
and Ian is not here today sorry I I love
Ian thank you for letting me keep the
seat warm but I'm Shane Cashman and uh
happy to be here and I write for
timcast.com I'm the author of tales from
the inverted world done a few profiles
recently on Kanye West and Carrie Lake's
election trial and thank you guys for
supporting me and saying some nice words
and we got that Brunson trial that
everyone's really excited about where
people think the Supreme Court will kick
Joe Biden out of office which is just
it's not gonna happen but we'll
definitely talk about that too and we
can talk about the Kerry Lake stuff
because that that article you wrote the
profile was actually really really great
so thanks for being here and then sir
just is here of course yo what's up
serge.com pushing buttons as always
let's get wrong let's jump into this
first story and uh for this first story
uh we're not throwing it to a website
I'm gonna throw it to Eliza apparently
uh you've got something to say yes I do
um so before I say what I'm about to say
um I just want to let everyone know that
I serve these survivors speaking here as
their Survivor Advocate and to anyone
that needs more information I will be
giving information at the end of this so
if survivors need to step forward and as
always anytime I'm on a show just know
that you can reach out to the human
trafficking hotline at any time I can
also give that number throughout this
stream as well
so let's get it going um so I tonight I
might use the word allegedly at certain
points this has been advised by legal
not because I don't believe the
survivors that I serve but it's the
legal way to do it so let's get it going
this is an official press release
these are not my words these this is a
survivor
as a survivor of the Tate Brothers I
understand how difficult it can be to
come forward and speak out about what
happened to you
but when social media gives us a glimpse
into the extreme harm that others cause
I feel obligated to step forward and
speak out against it
if these words can prevent one woman
from being an alleged victim of Andrew
and Tristan Tate
it justifies the risk that I'm taking
it can be scary overwhelming and you may
feel like you don't have anyone to turn
to
if you or someone you know is a survivor
know that you are not alone and that
there is help available
by coming forward together
we may be able to find Justice for
ourselves and prevent these perpetrators
from hurting anyone else
it is
it is a brave and important step towards
healing and finding closure
I know it can be hard to take this first
step but I promise you that there are
resources and people ready and available
to help you through this process don't
let fear or shame keep you from speaking
out let this be a reminder that you
deserve to be heard to feel safe and
supported you have you have the absolute
right to seek Justice this is a moment
and an opportunity for any victim of
these alleged perpetrators to stand up
and together we can recognize
vulnerability as power see the strength
in numbers and shine light on strength
of every single Survivor signed an
anonymous Survivor
the second statement
uh this will be Survivor two
for women who have been victimized we
didn't know the game
that was being played to hurt us
we know a game we know we didn't know a
game was being played at all
it's only after it happens and you lose
that and you lose that you know
whether the Loverboy method or some
other way
victims note that this game of deception
is used in in the court of public
opinion today
to the people who've made assumptions
about the victims before trial trial I
forgive you
I'm sorry
I won't ask
I won't ask
I won't ask those people to change their
opinion for our sake
I would just ask them to consider one
thing what if you're wrong
is it possible
and if it is
you can wait for the court to do its job
before attacking
those who those who have gone about the
correct legal process for justice
to all the victims out there I know you
I know how wounded you feel I have felt
that way too
I love each and every one of you for
being bragan brave enough to move
forward despite those feelings you are
loved
and know how strong you and and many
know how strong you have been signed
Anonymous Survivor
so if you are a survivor
of Andrew Tate
Tristan Tate or any co-conspirators in
this case
I need you to visit the website n c o s
e.com
ncos.com you'll see a click through
it'll go straight to the legal team
that's representing these two survivors
and I have a message of support
from a survivor of Epstein
Survivor of Epstein Maxwell Teresa J
helm
my support empathy and immense respect
to these courageous survivors brave
enough braving through the storm and
coming forward each of these women have
the soul of a warrior and the Heart of a
lioness
to the women to the women coming forward
and speaking to you you are changing the
world and hold and halting the vile
systems of exploitation make no mistake
you are a hero
you speak for so many
that have yet to breathe life into their
words you are taking your power back you
are returning you are returning it to
where it has always belonged within you
Justice is a journey and I encourage you
to to use each footstep to imprint your
Fierce will fight back demand
accountability drain the shame that was
never yours whoo that's cold uh to the
survivors that are currently developing
your strength to step to take that first
step of coming forward we are suited up
and you have an army of Warriors ready
to lock arms with you and that's true
take take the step reach out we are here
to help you and build a foundation of
your pathway to Justice
they they throughout they thought they
thought they'd bury you break three
Break Free through the barrier of
Silence take your power back with love
respect to each of you God bless you
Teresa J Helm Teresa J Helm is now
working full-time at nicosi and the Cozy
law will be uh representing the
survivors the American survivors and
Western survivors
so the Undertake case what do we know
about what Andrew Tate was doing what
what what do we have in terms of hard
facts so just based off my relationship
I'm not going to speak too too much
about
um you know the case but I will be
posting those statements onto my Twitter
account at elizablue sorry I cried too
um
elizablue
I'll be putting them there and then
survivors if you miss the the
um you know website to reach out you can
reach out there
um what we know
is that there are
um there are some folks that uh want to
get some justice
that's what we know that's what I know
so just to clarify that these are two
victims that are coming forward but
they're choosing to remain anonymous and
I'll tell you why and and I heard kind
of two words here trafficking and lover
boy yeah are those the main accusations
and are they suing for damages or are
they suing to get uh them arrested so
really quickly
um
the survivors are remaining Anonymous
and this was like a last minute decision
a day because of fear
um a fear as a result the legal team is
afraid for their safety
um and that's where we're at I'm in the
United States safety I'm afraid for my
own safety even sitting here speaking
about this
um
so that's where we're at with it um so
we need to make sure before those
survivors step forward uh if they do if
and when they choose because it's always
up to the Survivor you can be a part of
a lawsuit and be a Jane or John Doe
right
um but if and when these survivors
decide to step forward we need to make
sure that they are safe and this goes to
any Survivor out there that's listening
if you decide to step forward in this
case either as a Jane Doe or whatever
um but so this is a monetary lawsuit
then
if they're if they're remaining
Anonymous it's not going to be a
criminal proceeding in the United States
at least we'll see where it goes I mean
it depends on whom ever steps forward
you get what I'm saying but I mean if
this if this goes to a lawsuit then it's
a civil case where they can remain
anonymous if they can't remain anonymous
and if it's a choice between life or
death then we will not have them step
forward if it's not it's always up to
the Survivor no you said you're not
comfortable speaking about the evidence
here
um can you say that you did see did you
see any evidence yourself if you can't
if you can't tell us about this I'm not
going to speak about it and are you
confident or like
um from from what your information that
you're getting is this a solid case
from your experience working in this
kind of particular field
because I know there's still a lot of
things up in the air we still don't know
a lot but from from your kind of
understanding of how all this works um
how do you see this case I believe the
survivors that I serve and now leave
that there
do you trust the justice system if it
goes forward
um it's the system that we have yeah so
it doesn't really matter whether or not
I trust it it's the system that we have
does this tend to have like because I
have my own opinion on everything right
but uh I do everything legally
unlawfully and that's how we'll do it I
wish that there was a different system
but I can't live constantly in Utopia I
have to take action today the the main
challenge I have first I want to stress
have have there's a lot of people
defending Andrew Tate and by all means I
I have not watched everything he's ever
put out but I have seen a portion of of
uh many different podcasts people have
sent me I don't take those with a lot of
weight because out of contact statements
don't sway me seeing a 30 second or even
a four minute clip of Andrew Tate
talking about something I'll be like
okay I'll consider that he said that
I'll have heard that he said that but
without listening to the full hour I
don't like people being like Oh actually
I'll give an example
I thought people come to me and they're
like did you hear what Dave Rubin said
and I'll be like what did Dave Rubin say
and they'll be like he said this thing
and then I'll be like how do you know he
said that someone posted a clip on
Twitter and I'll be like come on bro
they post clips of me out of context all
the time I don't know if yeah that being
said Andrew Tate tells this story
frequently about how he had a bunch of
women who loved him and he said I'm
broke come come here we're gonna make
money and then he started a cam business
so there's there's a few questions the
first thing the first thing I'll say is
I understand why people are skeptical
we've not actually seen any evidence
from Romania other than accusations and
to be honest even the statements that
you have so so far didn't actually
assert anything
it's just people saying they were
survivors and they're looking for more
people to come forward sure
um so I mean what that's that's the
first step I suppose but for the time
being that's why the lawyers probably
said say allegedly because
we've not heard anything other than he
convinced women to go and work for him
and that it was it was exploitation and
illegitimate that he was a lover boy
that he was telling him how much he
loved him come out and then actually was
just putting him into these situations
so those accusations are there I guess
people are saying outside of uh I will
say this these these Anonymous
statements but also Vice put out a video
that allegedly comes from Witnesses we
have circumstantial evidence
the other thing I'll add to it is I can
also understand why people are skeptical
on this because
we've not gotten any accountability from
Epstein despite the fact that that guy
got arrested Maxwell was convicted we
know there were people flying on his
plane we know some of the people who are
on his Island some of these names have
been released and there's been literally
nothing done on it but then Andrew take
it's rated so people are asking
questions is it that Andrew Tate gained
power in a way that was outside of the
Epstein you know group and thus he's not
protected I'm releasing my own statement
later tonight might clear a little bit
of that up yeah like my statement's a
little different my statements come
straight at the at the throat but it's a
little long to read on your show to be
honest but like Andrew Tate didn't
donate to Democrats is that why he gets
arrested so I think there's a lot of
people who are just like we don't we
don't believe it because if they really
cared about trafficking they'd have gone
after this whole list I mean like Luke
named off a ton of people already were
implicated that they never went after so
this is why people are just like I don't
buy it and Andrew like I'm not I'm not
saying I know look I don't know anything
about Andrew Tate only a little only a
little bit right but I can certainly
understand why people are skeptical if
you get a guy who comes out and tells
people to break free from the machine
get away from the Matrix be masculine
and then they're like they ban them from
every platform then arrest them he's
never said any he doesn't say anything
that like Luke doesn't say like I mean
seriously like literally it's not like
he's like Reinventing the wheel and I
don't want to get too much into his I I
have no opinion on him and I I I'm gonna
let the Court decide I really will
um and I'll I'll go with that whatever
but I mean literally it's not like he's
coming out and like saying anything
that's super groundbreaking or you know
it's he's not Julian Assange
right you know what I mean he's not
Edward Snowden you know what I mean like
people act like uh you know like Tate's
saying something new or unique it's like
stuff that people like Luke and I say on
a daily basis like any day that ends in
why if he did what he's accused of doing
him and his brother then he needs to be
brought to Justice yeah but honestly I
understand why people find it hard to
believe when there's zero accountability
for the entire list of Epstein's clients
like the one that we haven't seen but
I'm talking about you know Bill Gates
flying on his plane Bill Clinton flying
on his plane things like that and
there's just no question don't talk
about it get the F out and then not to
mention you've got FTX where they're
trying they're going as light as
possible on this guy and obviously this
guy's a financial related thing but
these people in the club they get away
with everything so it very well may be
that Andrew Tate did bad stuff but he
ain't in the club and he's been speaking
out against the club so he's not
protected as we know for many decades
now the the federal government has been
aiding and protecting some of the worst
atrocious horrible behaviors
um but they've been working with big
Tech social media that also has been
aiding and abetting it to the point
where there's even victims coming
forward and saying hey there's these
photos there's these videos of me being
an underage child being hurt and abused
here Twitter looking at that listening
to the victim still deciding you know
what this doesn't violate our terms and
policies this is what happened here in
the United States your tax dollars as an
American went to aiding and protecting
an international trafficking operation
we're off off of the coast and the
Virgin Islands in the United States they
literally had an island that they flew
in powerful people and they procured
small children to them so obviously this
is a very important issue here this is
an issue that we can't forget this is an
issue that we need to to fight for since
everything that usually happens in our
Mainline political system is protecting
these individuals and very rarely do we
get any justice here now when it comes
to this particular case I I know you
don't feel comfortable talking about
some of the accusations or some of the
evidence here so I'm just I'm just
trying to to frame some questions so we
get a kind of bigger understanding here
um if I could ask
um did do you know these victims
beforehand did they come to the law firm
can you tell us a little bit about your
background with them and did you talk to
them and from like zero to a hundred how
much do you trust them
[Music]
all right for me right now Luke this is
a little different than the than the
John Doe one gender 2 Twitter lawsuit I
mean once things are filed then I have
Greenlight to go right now I'm in limbo
as a Survivor Advocate I've been serving
one of the survivors since summer since
since this past summer so I've been
serving this individual on a frequent
basis as their Survivor Advocate giving
direct service anyone that knows what a
victim's Advocate is or as a Survivor
advocate so I've been working with this
individual for quite some time the other
Survivor is more recent the
and that's all I'm going to say about
that right now just to not I don't want
to um break any of their it's I have to
be very mindful of what I say because I
don't want to give away any of their
identity from your experience you 100
believe them
um I believe every Survivor that I serve
but I also do my part in explaining due
diligence oh sorry explaining do I do my
due diligence and explaining due process
yeah because some people are gonna you
know take that question and are saying
well if you believe everyone how do we
know if someone's not you know using the
situation for their own personal benefit
I could see that and I could see that um
well number one they don't get any money
from me and they don't get I mean as you
can see they're not even coming out
their full name yet by the way they will
they these two survivors probably will
we just need to make sure that they're
safe
um you have to understand we're we
didn't necessarily know that the
Romanian law enforcement was going to
move ahead with what they did right then
so
um so it's it's putting the other
survivors that have been building their
case globally for a while we're all in
like hyper mode
um trying to
not catch up but sort of catch up and I
want to kind of I'm sorry sorry go ahead
keep why you why do you call them
survivors why is that the terminology
because I'm a Survivor Advocate no but
like what does Survivor mean like is
there a survivor of abuse or trauma does
that mean that there's a hyperpence like
the end result of the trauma or abuse is
to kill them
that's a really good point Tim
um I believe that anytime someone faces
trauma in this way a sexual assault
domestic violence human trafficking that
there is a high potential especially in
Children of their life to end right then
and there you never know how violent
it's going to get
um
and that's it's funny I think sometimes
people think I'm like kind of a nut job
because I'm so grateful to be alive all
the time I don't think they understand
what I've fully been through if you
anyone that survived that type of trauma
is very grateful to be alive because
sometimes I think about the times I
could have died and I'm shocked that I
didn't
so yes they survived they have survived
the trauma
um in legal terms you say victim
right I think I think a lot of people
take issue with the term Survivor
because okay Survivor is like you know
you survived a building collapse you
survived a murderer or you survived yeah
and and you know survive means to live
like it it I guess I suppose I would
Define it as living through something
which may have taken your life you
survived it's uh you're a survivor of a
shipwreck so I guess the question is and
I'm not saying it's not true you know
for a lot of these women I could imagine
that they do end up dead especially when
it comes to the more serious
international trafficking yeah they'll
get they get forced onto drugs into
opioid onto opiates because it'll make
them more manageable and then many of
them do die from this my my concern is I
I wouldn't I wouldn't say basically the
accusation of the Andrew on the
entertain thing it's probably iffy I
think the issue is a lot of leftists a
lot of woke people will call themselves
survivors when it's like someone said
nasty things to them or like they got
into a fight in the street you know what
I mean I don't like the word victim per
se though because victim means you're
staying there
oh I hate it when people call me a
victim that's one of my main complaints
sometimes uh corporate press or other
people on Twitter will say oh she's a
victim she's a victim I'm not a victim
I'm a survivor
so I I survived and I don't want to stay
in victim mentality and I don't want to
live there and I've chosen not to so
what else what other word would I say
I'm someone who has experienced uh you
know survivor's a shorthand for an
individual who has experienced that
specific trauma this is interesting yeah
we don't want to be victims we don't
want to live in victimhood that's part
of the problem with wokeness everything
makes them a victim so I can certainly
understand someone saying no I'm not a
victim I'm a Survivor then you get
people on the right who are like you
didn't survive you weren't gonna die you
know what I mean so it's like I I agree
I wouldn't want to say victim either
because you don't want to put yourself
in a weakened State you want to you want
to rise above and move forward with it
right yeah I guess people are just
asking you know what what is the Nuance
here is this related to kind of because
because abuse takes many forms is this
psychological abuse is this being a
lover boy or is this you know running a
human trafficking operation where you're
procuring children or small people what
what kind of degrees are we talking
about here I think that's what a lot of
people are asking sure and find out
let's break something down really
quickly I don't hate the term lover boy
but I kind of do lover boy is a is a
almost like a slang for the coercive
human trafficking is force fraud or
coercion for the sale of Labor or sex
lover boy would fall under the coercive
aspect if you are coerced into uh you
know sex or labor trafficking that would
be sort of what the lover boy the reason
why I don't prefer lover boys because
women can be traffickers so that to me
that's not a good I like to say coerced
if individuals were coerced into
um sexual exploitation that's what and
and I am a survivor of a coercive
relationship too unfortunately I ran a
poll and uh we have about seven thousand
four hundred seven thousand three
hundred votes and climbing do you think
Andrew Tate is guilty 84 said no
okay I mean that's fine I mean even the
Survivor said just let it you know let
the courts do their thing even though
even when the survivors said that in in
their statement but um you know I will
say this
to those who want to support survivors
please do during this time um whether it
be myself the survivors of Epstein
Maxwell or the so the um alleged
survivors of Tate uh
please do because they're um their
supporters are very loud
um the Bots are very loud
and I think it would be very helpful if
you're a supporter of survivors if you
speak out I think advice
skepticism like this though is a maybe a
consequence of the oversaturation of
false allegations from like a lot of the
last few years and like I was telling
people when those were happening like
the consequence of this is going to be
when people do step forward no one's
going to believe it anymore this is the
Tale As Old As Time people haven't
believed survivors since they started
stepping forward and they've only
recently said you know let me just say
real quick when Alex Jones was talking
about Epstein he was called crazy in a
conspiracy theorist and now 10 12 13
however long it's been all of a sudden
it's like well of course get whip out
that Alex Jones was right jars look man
I'll put it this way I understand a lot
of people like Andrew Tate and they
probably do because he's telling them to
step up push Back Against the Machine
and he's had several videos that we've
praised notably where he said whether I
really I really love it says whether I'm
happy or unhappy is irrelevant when I if
I wake up unhappy I can do the exact
same thing I would do if I I was happy
and I'm like that's a really good point
he had another video where he said you
gotta keep working you can't stop rocket
ship going to the Moon doesn't stop
halfway to chill out no it loses
momentum and it falls you got to keep
going people hear those messages they're
positive messages he says don't abide by
the machine break free from The Matrix
take the red pill get away from this he
hasn't said anything that we haven't all
been saying for literally ever this is
not new or groundbreaking information
he's charismatic he's not bad looking
and he built a platform that's not it
works for a lot of people I I mean yeah
sure so I'm not even mad that there's
somebody out there saying it that's the
vibe I like that information as well I'm
also I like that information but but we
what we said you know earlier this week
is I will look I will care about this
when they actually go after Epstein and
Maxwell's Client List no because this is
this is to me that's ridiculous I don't
care so no you don't you can do more
than one thing at once and you could
care about more than one set of
survivors or potential crimes at once
except I I agree but what we're seeing
here is this massive International and
corporate press effort going after this
guy and his brother sure while they have
protected along with the government
protected one of the most egregious
trafficking Rings we've ever seen and I
believe that the survivors of Epstein
deserve justice as well and I believe
that all co-conspirators in in the
Epstein case should be held accountable
as well and so I've served I've served
they're skipping over them I'm sorry I'm
not going to give them an inch because
they're skipping over absolutely what
you're not understanding is that
sometimes there is a trickle effect
there are still things happening with
the Epstein case and I want to remind
everyone out there watching every time
you think that the Epstein case has done
more happens and you got you know
there's only so much that that the
survivors can do and there's only so
much that they that there's only so much
that that the survivors can do but they
are still fighting trust me this is
nowhere that is nowhere near done you
can't equate one case for another case
there are two totally different cases so
let's hopefully push for justice with
the Epstein Maxwell case and the all
co-conspirators are held accountable but
also you can care about another case and
hope that if if Justice needs to be
received if we could get a little bit of
clarification here I just I also want to
talk about the vice piece a little bit
here but we know what was happening with
Epstein to a certain level which was
really really bad outside of the legal
perspective what do you think was
happening here with the Tate Brothers
what do you think they were doing uh
um how were they running their operation
what was really going on here from your
perspective I'm not going to speak about
that okay I'm sorry I'm very no no no no
no no no no just so people understand
the level of like hey what Epstein was
doing was extremely horrible and bad
right I will say taking small children
that were like like Todd like like nine
years old and and then bringing them
onto Islands to you know have other
powerful people fly in do whatever
that's really bad so so how bad from
your perspective I know you you don't
have to answer it but how bad is that
related to tastes abuse isn't like a um
because every human's different abuse
can affect an individual differently so
it's not like um there's a word I want
to use right now but I can't I just want
to keep the show clean like uh it's not
a Tit for Tat game when it comes to
abuse it's not like one abuse is worse
than one abuse I've met survivors who
were sexually assaulted one time and
it's harder on them that one that one
abuse is harder on them than survivors
who have been sexually abused locked up
chained for a very long time it doesn't
so this is we don't play a Tit for Tat
game when it comes to abuse if you're
abused you're abused so why don't we
just let we'll let everything happen the
way it's supposed to legally and
lawfully and we'll I'm all I'm asking
and I get what you're saying Tim but
there's a reason I'm not part of the
machine
I'm not part of the machine I don't even
work for nicosi who's representing the
case
I'm not part of the machine
so if I'm sitting here saying I'm
serving to the survivors in fact I've
broken bread with some of the people
that have are really super cool with
Tate so I'm not part of the machine so I
guess the real question is are are folks
going to believe like okay Liza's part
of this big conspiracy also I'm not part
of the corporate press in fact quick
reminder to everyone at home I just went
through my uh dreads where I've been
getting dragged by the corporate press
left and right
before we move on to the next story I
wanted to talk about this Vice report
that just also recently came out because
they detailed how seven years ago he was
also accused of sexual sexual assault
and physical abuse in the United Kingdom
but from that case the UK authorities
actually declined to prosecute him and
Tate released the statement about this
specifically through his lawyer while in
Romanian custody saying specifically
that the individuals accusing him were
trying to go after money saying quote
the police understood after the
investigation that I am innocent and the
police found messages from the girls
phones where they were talking between
themselves and planning to lie about me
end quote that's what Andrew Tate said
according to the response of this Vice
report that specifically detailed how he
punched one girl in the arm and
allegedly forced himself on another girl
in in a shower from one of the girls who
was who was seeing it uh the woman also
decided to remain anonymous here but
this Vice report is of course something
that everyone is talking about and
saying this is not the first time he's
being accused of something like this as
well did you see that advice report and
actually if the survivors out there are
listening that step forward and that I
appreciate your bravery and hopefully
um you know I hope you get some justices
as well if it's you know that's I really
appreciate your bravery and actually I
want to say something else I'm sorry for
the way that the internet dragged you
um
and I've been there and it socks and
keep going
keep going and actually reach out to
nicosi law as well because we can
connect you with some of the survivors I
want to jump to the story here which uh
it's in line with this it's from NBC
news they wrote on musk's Twitter users
looking to sell and trade child abuse
material are still easily found a review
conducted by NBC News found dozens of
accounts and hundreds of tweets claiming
to sell child sexual abuse material I
gotta stop right there and just say this
Elon Musk takes over Twitter and
immediately goes to task of cleaning
this stuff up for years Twitter allowed
and protected not only groomers but
active abusers of children I'd like to
point out that James Lindsay and I James
Lee got a permanent suspension for
calling out actual grooming I had two
tweets removed because I there was an
image of an adult human male showing
children graphic images and I said they
are grooming your kids and Twitter
locked my account and actually it's
right here look at this the the prop we
have from the Jack pesobic gag says
Twitter suspends Tim pool for calling
out groomers Tim goes off
now Elon Musk comes in and almost
immediately cleans up a good majority of
this all of a sudden now the corporate
press is like on Elon musk's Twitter
where was any of this reporting when
this was going on under the nose of Jack
Dorsey and Vegeta
conspiracy theory
and this is why
I think
I I do want to stay focused on on now as
we get into the Twitter story but I am
not surprised that people hear the Tate
story and they say I don't trust it and
then because you act you have the active
protection from the Press from the legal
department from International
authorities defending the stuff on
Twitter protecting the at the Epstein
Client List and things like that this is
why people are just like I don't believe
it when they know what you don't like
the corporate press they go after you
with with the same things that you don't
like like when uh they went after Matt
Walsh saying he was a groomer and James
Lindsay and Lindsay too James Lindsay
went to a conference where he spoke in
it and I think you I think he spoke at
the same conference as Nikki Klein Nikki
Klein I'm pretty sure she was a member
of nixium right I believe so yeah and so
they are now trying they've been running
the smear campaign let's say James
Lindsay comma a known associate of the
nixium sex cult they met at a conference
like it would be like you get like you
guys being associated with me because
you're here talking to us about ideas
correct that's why it's just it's really
hard when the when this when the
corporate press comes out and the these
authorities come out and they're like
well you know Andrew Tate did these
things people's immediate reaction is BS
If he if he was actually doing this and
you cared you'd have gone after The
Client List and if you actually cared
you would have gone after the people on
Twitter is it James Lindsay's not saying
that he does these things where uh Tate
does
well so so James Lindsay's there's
videos of Tate saying he had women who
loved him working for him producers it
was on his website yes so I mean that's
the difference James Lindsay's like oh
let's talk about uh cultural Marxism and
that so that's not his brand
right I'm just saying that
NBC news right now is trying to accuse
musk of what what what Jack dorsey's
Twitter was doing 100 not even a
question and Elon Musk is trying to shut
it down yeah well number one musk
inherited a crime scene he inherited a
decades old problem and I used decade as
sort of a benchmark I'm sure I could go
back further but that was when the first
piece in the guardian that I've been
able to find uh there could be others
out there talking about the child sexual
abuse material problem on Twitter uh was
a decade ago so Elon Musk purchased a
platform that had a decades-old problem
and now uh the corporate press once
again first and foremost I'd like to
pull up every article that the corporate
media wrote about this issue on Twitter
specifically prior to Elon Musk
purchasing this platform how about every
article from like what was it salon and
the New York Times that have been
actively defending pedophilia or like
the the Ted Talk from that woman where
she actively defended it there was
recently uh what was it New Zealand is
is it New Zealand now that's that's not
they're using the word Maps they're
using the phrase Maps like yo Scotland
Scotland Scotland
these people are groomers it is obvious
what they're doing and why they're doing
it and they're they're using this now
against Elon Musk because accuse your
enemy of what you do they're projecting
yeah we saw the the cultural landscape
we saw the groundwork being laid this
this furthest larger kind of grooming
activity for a very long time and and
it's so it's so Insidious it's so
dishonest it's it's so insane that
there's corporate media Outlets
literally calling for the the
excusing a lot of this Behavior by
calling it minor attracted persons uh a
police department in Scotland usually
used that against a known pedophile
um so seeing this and also seeing you
know individuals like yoel Roth the
former head of trust and safety at
Twitter who literally wrote a thesis a
thesis um supporting children using
Grindr
um and now now finally the corporate
media has a problem with this kind of
behavior because Elon Musk is in charge
of Twitter that's but bullcrap they were
aiding and abetting it for such a long
time and this goes along with I I don't
know let me know what you think but this
goes along uh towards a larger agenda
trying to normalize a lot of this sick
Behavior I fully agree that's exactly
what I think it is I wish I had better
news for everyone
that's exactly what it is no I'm serious
because if they can make the world so
sick and depraved uh what Have We Become
as a society we won't fight back if we
won't fight for children we definitely
won't fight for our own Freedom under
tyranny I was talking to James Lindsay
at Turning Point USA and then we went up
on stage and James brought this up it
starts with drag queen Story Hour and
then when you come out and say drag is
an adult inherently sexualized
performance they go no no no these are
just people in costumes reading books
it's like it's like if they were just
like a fairy princess and you're like no
no no no no no drag is effectively
stripping and burlesque okay it's like
burlesque not a proof of kids but
they're only reading books then they
grab they graduate to
drag queen all ages drags you know all
ages drag show now they're actually
doing the burlesque but it's just it's a
dance show with costume change then you
get San Antonio sexual uh and in Florida
they did it too bringing kids out
talking openly and overtly about sex
simulating sexual activities because the
whole process from start to finish was
grooming yeah then you have social media
promoting degenerate Behavior showing a
lot of outrageous content especially in
people's users user feeds especially on
Instagram of some of the most borderline
pornographic content that you could even
imagine and then you have of course porn
that's readily available free for
everyone as long as you have an internet
connection you could get to it and a lot
of children are getting it to it and
it's rewiring their brains in very
negative ways over sexualizing them
making sure that they could never have a
strong family unit and when you break
down the family unit you have more
people being victims you have more
people being picked off you have more
people being on their own and left in a
more vulnerable situation and I think
you know there's many layers to this and
we could keep compounding it and we
could keep connecting the dots but
there's a lot of freaking dots I know
people with uh kids in elementary school
who saw some text messages about these
young kids talking about being like in
polyamorous relationships
I mean I guess my question actually
I'm in a room with men
how do men feel about the world headed
in this
Direction because anti-human but what
I guess at a certain point
I do kind of wonder
when the men are going to do a thing and
I know that makes me not uh you know
feminist or whatever and I'm not um I
only am out here doing what I do because
there's
let me not get myself fully
if I if there were I don't want to be
doing this job
I don't want to be protecting women that
are being abused
um I want good men of the world to be
protecting these women but because there
aren't enough out here I have to be out
here
I agree what are what are what are men
gonna do what well or maybe I'm wrong I
don't know this is like a question that
I haven't fully thought through that's a
good question the men in this room Are
The Men Who call out Epstein okay and
Luke of course longer than I think the
rest of us yeah shout out to Luke I
didn't know about all your hard work
before I came last time I remember I
didn't know and now I know and I
appreciate that it was Furious seeing
VH1 promote Epstein and everyone in the
alternative media screaming about it and
it wasn't just Jones it was a lot of
other people a lot of independent
journalists including also the Miami
Herald shout out to them they were one
of the few organizations out there Mike
cernovich and the Daily Mail
surprisingly one of the few
organizations that that first started to
actually talk about this in a very
serious way but first it was Independent
Media before anyone else I just want to
say I I was ragging on The Daily Mail
earlier because they're obsessed with
Meghan Markle and Princess was it Harry
or whatever but equally they would not
shut up about prince Andrew during the
Epstein off and I'm like that I like so
here's my point about the men if you
look at the polls uh the polling Vox
found that like 45 of millennial men
vote Democrat and then like 55 percent
just shy 55 55 foot Republican whereas
for women it's about 70 Democrat and
like 28 Republican because there's like
some you know like green party stuff in
there
I I think you have half of these guys
who are weakened effeminate bottom of
the bell curve guys who will not stand
up defend the people they love and care
about they will not be masculine but I I
must admit as much as I have disdain for
these guys I have more disdain for the
system that tells them masculinity is
bad and and to to be ashamed of being
masculine and that's that's one of the
one of the things we see here so it's
interesting I feel about it just hit me
with a good Twitter comment he said
legal and local
legal and local what is it elaboration
yeah that's the solution legally local
that's what I hope that's what he was
referencing to otherwise I'm putting
words in his mouth I think I think one
of the reasons that people don't want to
believe yeah anything about Andrew Tate
yeah is because this message of opposing
the machine plays into a larger picture
of the machine is telling men not to be
masculine which in turn is resulting in
men not protecting women and children
and the Machine is telling is advocating
for hardcore degeneracy and so I think
for a lot of people I'm I'm not here to
accuse or or defend Andrew Tate but but
I think what I see from a lot of people
in the chat when they're split on this
is yeah if this guy at the very least is
saying exercise workout be strong be
tough and break from the machine the end
result of that puts a stop to a lot of
this whatever it is he's accused of
doing you know what I mean
sure so um so galane did a lot of nice
things too she was at a I mean you so
abusers like a serial killer isn't a
serial killer like 24 hours a day seven
days a week so I'm not saying that some
of the things yeah yeah you should work
out and eat right no no you should break
free from the machine and you should
um you know I'm not saying every man has
to be a masculine man because that's not
a thing that I believe but
I mean yes you should work out and eat
right you should break free from the
machine you should break free from The
Matrix or whatever you should be red
pill white pill past all that you know
but
um you should also not abuse people I
think a lot of the problem is a
consequence of what Luke was saying
about the family structure being
destroyed and a lot of people today a
lot of men today don't have father
figures and they're raised with the
government being their parent the
colleges being their parents uh they're
if they have a say at home mom or dad
that that parent is out all the time so
they're kind of being raised by I think
mostly bad people but also when you're
not strong when you don't have a family
unit You're vulnerable and the Predator
class which is made up of a lot of
Psychopathic politicians and
billionaires out there preys on a lot of
individuals who can't defend themselves
who are not strong enough to do so or if
they are victimized they're not going to
be able to go to anybody because they
have no family member in order to
protect them or even report that they're
missing I do get what you what you're
saying though Tim it's okay sorry oh no
I want to pull up this story this is
from The New York Times this is is from
about a year and a half ago yeah as a
woman was raped train riders failed to
intervene police say and this was just
the first story I was able to pull up
about five years ago now I think it was
five years ago I did a video on my main
Channel men are refusing to help women
and children it got millions of views
and it was just like this 15 minute
thing of me talking about there were a
handful of stories one
a woman was on a train and some guy
started getting in her face schmoozing
on her and being really aggressive and
no man would intervene and then she was
really angry and she was like why
wouldn't any man stand up for me well
there's a lot of reasons why they won't
do it another story I read years ago
this may be like 10 years ago now at
this point a guy was in a store and he
there was a there was a journalist who
was in a store saw a child crying with
no parent seemingly lost yeah and they
and she said I saw a man walk up walk
towards this kid looking at the kid
concerned and stopped looked around
turned around and walked away
they ran up to the child like this
person and got a security guard to help
the person and then the reporter said
she then ran to the man and asked him
why he turned around and didn't help the
kid and the man said because I would be
accused of having kidnapped that kid and
I don't want to be involved
that is a crazy prospect that we have
this story from Philadelphia where a
woman was being raped on the train in
front of people and what did they do
most of them just leave me alone some of
them started filming no one did anything
there's a lot of reasons why men are
outright refusing to help women one I
think some men have disdain for for
modernity that we we're in this era of
toxic masculinity is toxic toxic women
can do whatever they want and you know
without without consequence that's how
they feel I'm not saying it's true and
so you'll get a guy who's probably
watching him and be like screw him I
don't care not my problem whereas there
is an inverted there I was just watching
um the imitation game about Alan Turing
and uh it's it's so it's such a BS
because he didn't he didn't crack Enigma
I was reading up on it was like some
Polish guy actually who did but he built
the machine but anyway they he's trying
to recruit this woman and she's like it
would be indecorous of me to come and
work for his majesty because it would be
around men and so then he's like you can
work and be in the women's dorms and
then he can't go to her place because
he's a man that's the alternative right
a society where the men and women are
separated when the men are
overprotective you get that when the men
feel like they're not allowed to protect
women and children they'll be punished
imprisoned or insulted for being
masculine you get the inverse is there a
happy medium or what do you guys feel
about this I'll just I'll just say like
someone super chatted we're not allowed
to protect women and children anymore so
why would we and I'm like what can I say
to that yep and your cops don't even
protect maybe
um women have given off an impression
that we don't want to be protected or
loved or looked after maybe that's the
problem and maybe it should be up to
each woman what is the best for her I
think that's important but like I've
come out and said it like I want to be
protected I want to be loved I don't
want to be out here doing this alone I
don't want to be fighting these demons
and ghouls alone like it sucks I'm
scared I actually am scared I'm scared
I'm gonna get killed I think a lot of
people have a problem facing that
darkness and they choose to just turn
away I think a lot of uh our society I
get what you've started like widespread
I've got a lot of fathers yeah tell me
they can't look well can't look at what
I'm thinking about what I'm talking
about when I'm posting but I I don't
want to you struck something in me Tim
and I don't want to forget it I I do
understand why people are very skeptical
of these stories you should be a little
but not to the point where you harass
survivors what can I do as a Survivor as
a public Survivor and as an advocate to
at least
maybe convey the story better I don't
know what I can do to make people
believe people don't believe my story
they date evidence yeah just getting
what evidence and are are survivors
supposed to bring because it's like we
bring evidence and it's always not
enough well you know it's never enough
it's like always something well look
look at look at uh Amber Heard okay she
she writes this op-ed where she it's
vague and you know she has this
narrative that Johnny Depp is the bad
guy
and then the full story kind of comes
out and it's like well they're both kind
of ish heads to each other but she was
definitely being abusive towards him and
so what happens is you have this
long-standing it's been a a decade or
longer the you know believe all women
and our our legal systems built upon
innocent until proven guilty and the
right to confront your accusers yes so
immediately people take issue with
Anonymous accusations without evidence I
mean that's especially with Julian
Assange being falsely accused that that
pissed off a lot of people especially
anti-war movement because then they
dropped it and it was fake to begin with
and they use as an excuse to lock this
guy for a decade and prevent him from
doing his work Assange was accused of
rape a lot of people don't know this no
no he wasn't even accused of rape it was
like it was it was it was but that's
what the corporate media ran with it's
the corporate media ran with Julian
Assange rapist you know that that was a
huge story that of course uh allowed the
general public to be like yeah he's
guilty yeah maybe he should be in jail
and then they put him up in solitary if
they have to run away if if this story
about the train in in the New York Times
here's the problem
if a guy on that train grabbed the man
who was raping that woman and stopped
him
then he would probably get arrested in
church yeah he would yeah he would
but I think what's important is that
we're having this conversation right and
and I I actually I have a question for
the audience that's um I got a question
if uh let's try to figure out how I can
phrase this for you guys
put a one in the chat if if you
would attack the rapists to stop him
knowing you would get locked up in jail
and put a two in chat if you would not
want to risk your freedom in life for a
random woman
did that work did that did that make
sense yeah I think that's good question
actually I think the truly masculine the
real masculine is a man saying let them
let them come I'm not letting this man
hurt this woman
that's that's in line with the come and
take it you will try to aggress upon me
you will try to infringe upon my rights
but I will stand firm on what I know to
be true but there's gonna be a lot of
people who are maybe more cynical and I
know you mean this disrespectful way
because I can understand it where
they're like dude if they if if they
want to keep advocating for this and
voting for it if 70 of millennial women
keep one of voting be voting for these
policies why would I go to jail for them
when they asked for it and I mean like
ask for the policies not obviously to be
attacked so one of my rules is that uh
I'm not so no it's split in the chat
it's ones and twos sometimes I want to
uh so it's difficult as a human to hear
some of these stories especially about
children and not want to seek vigilante
justice so I understand those who do but
I am of no use if I'm in prison or
jailed because I decided to go out on a
freaking LARP and do things the you know
whatever way but so it's like you're
you're on a train and a guy grabs him
and throws her down yeah and he's on the
train raping her and and there is people
saying like if I intervene not only will
I get hurt but I'll get arrested I'm not
doing it that's crazy to me it like
maybe I'm wrong I've never seen a sexual
I mean I don't well let me make sure I'm
not uh I don't think I've ever said I've
never been in that situation so it's
really difficult
to know what you would do I mean does
this gentleman have a knife does he have
a gun like is he whack I mean what are
we talking you know this is why I'm an
anarchist because number one
I'm serious I'm serious this is an
argument to be made here it's not a
perfect argument but the police are slow
to respond right this happened in
Philadelphia where people can't defend
themselves if a woman was able to have a
gun and be able to defend herself these
larger sexual assault crimes these large
rapes wouldn't be happening as much as
they are happening mainly because a lot
of women are left defenseless and the
one way to have this equalizer is to
allow people to be able to defend
themselves which is illegal in places
like Pennsylvania which is absolutely
crazy but
um again there's been so many instances
of police officers watching people
getting stabbed getting hurt and just
not doing anything not responding so I
just wanna I wanna add too uh in terms
of the chat and the super chats the
debate the people who disagree with you
but other people who are making other
points
I I'm really digging this like everybody
who's commenting saying you're wrong I
disagree everybody who's commenting
saying I can't believe people wouldn't
help her everybody who's saying like you
know how could you if the machine is
going to come against you and this is
what they're voting on that like I think
the discussion absolutely is just is
just fantastic so but it's good it's
good that we're having these
conversations uh talking about it is
better than and also one of the things
that I love is when you think through
these situations before you're actually
in one because these are all things that
could happen
to you in real life it's not a movie
this is not a test so you should be
thinking through in advance what you
would do uh and too much to what uh Luke
was just saying I am a fully armed
Survivor of human trafficking no two
ways about it no no no discussion yeah
absolutely so and I encourage pardon no
we're not going to talk about all that
but uh more personal Liberty and more
ability for human beings to be able to
defend themselves equally against
criminals who will always have firearms
and weapons it took me a while to get
there I had a conversation with mash
Trey because I was always very scared of
guns and this is great oh yeah he's he's
great isn't he
um and I had a conversation with
Monastery and my mom and I went and we
got uh geared up for her 60th birthday
so it was really fun but um and now I
feel very empowered and um and I feel
ready I just don't want to be abused
again or any have anything happen and I
feel like that's the only great
equalizer and training don't forget to
train no you have to train part of it
too you know yeah that's part of it too
you know what you know the terrifying
reality I think is
the people in these cities like
Philadelphia would prefer more rape
victims and less dead rapists
and there's an interesting idea there I
don't want anyone dead but think about I
was thinking about this in terms of guns
if this woman on the train had a gun
even like a Derringer with like a you
know 22 in it or something this guy
would have gotten off a real fast and
and he'd probably survive but there's a
reality that one a woman should be able
to protect herself if a man is trying to
to take her she could she should I
believe she should be allowed to use
whatever Force necessary to protect
herself from that man but this would
mean that man dies
now the left's argument you see it all
the time there was like uh I can't
remember the story but there's been a
bunch of them where a guy was like
breaking into someone's house and he got
shot and killed and they go you didn't
have to kill him you know you could have
let him victimize you and then it's just
like why is it incumbent upon the victim
to assume they're going to survive the
attack instead of using whatever Force
they can to try and survive the attack
so so the the logic of the left on this
tends to be they would rather the the
rape victim get raped and survive
because it means both people live then
the woman not get raped but then kill
somebody you see what I mean
like that that's their logic
okay there was a there was a guy like
Rob the liquor store
and then he got shot and killed and they
were like but you didn't have to kill
him
and the guy's like he came in with a gun
to my liquor store I thought I was gonna
die no he was just robbing he was just
robbing you this is the sad reality I
don't want anybody yeah you don't know
until you're in that situation and if
it's a life or death situation and it
could be and it very well could be you
don't know what level of insanity you're
dealing with I don't want to live in a
world where it's the victim's fault or
responsibility for having been attacked
I think if you are being victimized you
have a right to defend yourself with
whatever Force you have available to you
and I think you have a right to keep in
bear arms that means in this
circumstance that rapist would have died
and that and that I got I gotta be
honest I don't like this guy or had nuts
shut off for sure he or seriously
injured I don't want him injured look I
want him stopped and if the only way to
stop him because because women have less
muscle mass less bone density is to be
armed and that means this guy gets shot
I would rather the woman not be raped
and this guy gets stopped but it is it
is horrifying to be like there's an end
result where someone gets hurt well you
know what don't attack people because it
is your fault my view is if you're a
rapist who attacks a woman and then you
get shot you should be criminally
responsible for the that bullet to
yourself because you initiated the
aggression and with how incompetent
police officers are or lazy when it
comes to Prosecuting or actually getting
actual Justice here that that's that's
going to be maybe one of the sure ways
to actually get some kind of redemption
here if you are committing a crime
and then someone dies in the process of
that crime you the criminal responsible
so for example you and a friend are
let's say uh guy a and guy beat rob a
liquor store liquor store clerk shoots
and kills guy B guy a in many states
will get charged for for that like
there's other circumstances too probably
a better way to describe it is if you're
in the act of committing a crime and a
bystander has a heart attack and dies
they will charge you for you know in
many states interesting my view of this
if you are a so I don't care who the
person is if you are a criminal and
you're attacking a woman or or anybody
and then you get shot you should get
charged with aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon even though someone else
shot you you started it it's your fault
maybe that's a little aggressive but I
don't know if if the law has actually
stopped the crimes I actually just kind
of feel like if these cities allowed
people to keep in bear arms I actually I
think Philadelphia is not good
Pennsylvania tends to be ain't nobody's
gonna attack a woman if they know she's
strapped
yep but they're promoting lawlessness to
not have to be strapped yeah but but
that would be nice I agree like but I
know it's not utopian I can't live in
like yeah I get it I mean there are evil
people in the world regardless of what
happens or whatever laws put in place
you have to be prepared to defend
yourself and even 200 years ago it was
Bears wolves coyotes yeah there was
always danger but in and capistan and
kevistan there always is to be a little
different I mean there's nothing getting
rid of danger I mean bad people will
always find a way to happen
did you ever see that video Luke we
probably talked about it where the guys
playing the game city-states have you
ever heard this yes we talked about this
so many times and it proves what I've
talked about for a very long time it's a
video game so it's real life okay it's a
video game where you build a city-state
buildings factories Apartments housing
Etc and you set policies more taxes
lower taxes more authoritarian with
police less and so this guy
um I think you guys are gonna know he is
because it's such a good video he's like
I'm gonna get rid of all government no
taxes just let everything go crazy it's
gonna be a crime ridden hell hole there
were So eventually he's like wait what's
happening there were ski resorts
everywhere there was 0 poverty
everything was a skyscraper every
citizen was super wealthy and he's like
what's going on how is this happening
there's like no government
thank you
can we try this experiment once yeah I
mean and even when it was practiced
someone like in Singapore or in Hong
Kong especially with the larger
Financial ramifications of a
laissez-faire kind of government we had
that we had Prosperity we had so much
people progressing and getting wealthy
and getting rich and helping each other
and so much less poverty whenever the
government doesn't intervene and when
they do they're just acting like thugs
they're just acting like gangsters
getting a cut of their money screwing
everyone else over and this is why I
think the biggest enemy towards humanity
is big government and we should always
try to be pushing against it as much as
we can but still possible with like the
population we have now who is so like
subservient there's gonna be a messy
period where there's going to be a lot
of people winning Darwin Awards but
maybe they deserve to win Darwin Awards
right no no let's be real all right
let's be real like would you rather have
people in Darwin Awards or would you
rather have uh you know the federal
government use your tax dollars in order
to send small children to private
islands so so uh people could go there
and do something else what's the lesser
of two evils
um you know Waging War nuclear Holocaust
we could get into bio weapons we could
get into it what's the lesser of of two
evils what's what's going to lead to
less harm in my personal opinion what
I'm describing I I just wanna I wanna
stress this again like the people who
are chatting super chatting arguing and
very defensive of Tate the people who
are there's less critical of them I just
got to say like I feel like this
discussion is one of the best
discussions we've had on a variety of
issues to be completely honest like
again agreed with all of the people who
are disagreeing and arguing and
defensive or against like this is this
this feels substantive no I and I love
the conversation this is the thing that
people don't realize about me
regardless if it's good or bad or if
people are talking trash on me or
talking about my story or whatever I'm
just happy we are having these
conversations we used to live in a time
where a Survivor if they wanted to
release a statement would have to wait
for the corporate press to care and then
green light it for to maybe be in the
back of the New York Times now I'm a
Survivor of human trafficking who served
survivors came up here on Independent
Media told you folks and now it's out to
many people and we can all talk about it
but we're still talking about you know
human trafficking domestic violence sex
abuse child abuse child sexual abuse
material we are talking about these
things and let me tell you it makes
Predators Big Mad Predators down bad and
abusers down bad and that's the way it
should be you know I think that before I
was searching for this answer like well
where are the men well maybe it's you
gentlemen here giving me the platform to
have the conversation so that we can
keep the conversation going and other
survivors don't feel alone maybe that is
what men are doing and maybe I wasn't
seeing uh the full vision well men
should also be protecting women in
public as well like that's the that's
obviously it's like these train stories
but this too the conversations
let me pull up the story uh this is a
tweet from NPR highlighted by Libs of
tick tock who said that uh NPR's big mad
that genderqueer is being banned NPR
wrote in 2020 the book genderqueer
received multiple honors and was headed
for a fourth printing by Spring of 2022
it topped the ala's list of most
challenged books
and you know why I I can't show it on
YouTube i i i the NPR article doesn't
show it there are graphic sexual images
in that book and they and Amazon listed
as 18 plus everybody knows we have it
right here yeah check it out it's right
there it's it's Ian Ian got it and I can
pull up the image there's there's a few
Wow have you ever you know this one
right yes of course I know this I I'm I
can't even I know it's that proves that
we're in dystopian world I am I am
looking right now at I can't even show
it but but you guys mostly know and this
is the crazy thing because people need
to see they need they need to see this
book was being given to kids and so this
whole thing this book not only do I
believe its intent is to groom children
by exposing look they say it's 18 plus
on Amazon but they're giving it to grade
schools and that's why it's being
challenged introducing kids to Kink it
is not reproduction it is not sex ed it
is kink it is kink advocacy because
they're showing toys and prosthesis and
things like that to children
this is part of grooming and radical
gender Theory which is resulting in as
we were just talking about men not
protecting women one the attack on
masculinity you know masculinity is a
fantastic thing and so is femininity
they are they are it's yin yang they are
two pieces of this great puzzle of of
the world they complement each other but
for some reason now I mean I assume I I
know many people can just assume the
reason the narrative is that one side is
extremely awful and bad no matter what
and so what you end up with is men who
don't want to be masculine they're being
told to wear dresses they're being told
to be effeminate and this results in men
not standing up and protecting women it
results in women then being victimized
it results in women then advocating for
a world and policy and law in which they
have no protection from males and so
it's it's akin to gun law in this way in
the city of Chicago you can't have guns
like you sort of can it's very very
difficult what happens rampant gun crime
people being shot left and right but
good innocent law-abiding people can't
have guns in terms of radical gender
Theory it results in good humbly
masculine men being unable to stand up
for what they believe in to protect
women and children and even other men
and it results in the most toxic and
evil men exploiting and taking advantage
of women with with no hindrance it's
anti- future I think I've heard Lou say
this before and I agree with him when he
says like we're more in like a cultural
revolution in terms of like Mao in the
60s with China and when I see this stuff
with what they're doing to children I
see it as like a way for them to destroy
the future like Mao destroyed the past
and a lot of Chinese culture language
art statue stuff like that
um to then recreate the future and then
by destroying the innocence of children
they are literally destroying the humans
of the future
um and that's like so scary to me I'm
watching kids young kids who are
inheriting nihilism from their parents
who refuse to stand up to do anything
against the bad stuff and it's just like
well you're screwed because how do you
fix that how do you fix nihilism in a
nine-year-old you know you know what I I
I view myself as a positive nihilist
yeah and there's negative nihilist let
me explain so I can give you a very
rudimentary understanding of nihilism
basically like how would you describe it
nothing matters total meaninglessness
totally meaninglessness but hold on hold
on I don't disagree with that I take it
to a positive Place meaning is what you
decide it is life has the value that you
ascribe to it if you so I had this I had
this phase when I was younger where I
was like what's the point of anything
where does this all go and then I
thought to myself if this doesn't go
anywhere
then there's nothing holding me back
from trying to do the best things I can
in terms of what this world considers to
be good like positive and constructive
and then I meet a lot of people a lot of
left activists especially who are
negative nihilists nothing matters so
why don't we just Burn It Down for fun
right you can think nothing matters I
have no problem with that it's what do
you do next for me it was like if there
is no inherent mattering to anything
that means we assign that value we
decide and if I decide I'm going to
decide on good things making people feel
better giving them good long-term
Solutions longevity Family Life creation
exploration those are all good things
I'm with you on the positive nihilist
thing because I'm the same way because I
see a lot of meaninglessness in the
world and I'm finding meaning in my
family and in my own religion that I'm
working on but like I think what we can
agree on is we see a hope in people
whereas the negative nihilus want to
destroy people and themselves and that's
why the anti-human anti-future comes in
and I think the positive nihilists
as more rare as it might be I'd imagine
like my view of the world is I wouldn't
call it absolute nihilism I would say I
do see a lot of things as being
meaningless but I do think there is
meaning to us why we are here why humans
exist and so I would I would find myself
more in agreement with a staunch
conservative like you know Christian or
religious person who who genuinely
believes in larger purpose and something
bigger than themselves I'm like halfway
there that's why I say I believe in God
but I'm not like religiously theistic or
anything if you are someone who believes
there's no meaning but that if that's
the case we should be the best people we
can be because we made the meaning like
if you if you don't think there's a God
of morality and you think nothing
matters and then you decide from that I
want to make sure everybody lives the
best they can because it's up to us to
decide I think that kind of person is
going to be more aligned with people of
faith and religion who who are of a
similar now not saying everybody every
religious person is a good person right
oh yeah of course not so saying the good
people of faith and the good people of
positive impact will work together with
smiles on their faces despite my
nihilism even it might be mostly
positive I believe in Free Will and I
think a lot of people who are negative
nihilists are determinists who believe
that there's no everything's set out for
them so there's no point to their life
um and I know those people personally
and I'm I I argue with them on the ideas
of Free Will and determinism I think
determinism is another anti-human idea
that means you're stuck in whatever path
you're in and there's no point these
people have no fight out of their
negativity it it
it bums me out oh yeah like I've told
this story you know I'd Occupy Wall
Street there was this prominent writer
and we had a Converse like they were
nasty to me and they were smack talking
and then when we talked in private is
this woman and she was very much just
like oh I don't care about anything I'm
an ilist it's just fun and I was like
well look I agree with you that for a
lot of people like you look through life
you look at everything and you ask
yourself to what end if I do this then
what if I have kids then what if I build
this then what what's the point why not
do something else and I was like so I I
take from that the desire to build
something positive that has a good
result that grows and she goes yeah but
if it doesn't matter then isn't it just
fun to burn it all down and I'm like not
really people suffer from that and if
there are people who do have meaning in
life and you're causing them pain pain
is bad but this was the mentality of
these like antifa types oh yeah that's
why they don't care to throw a brick
through a window it feels good and who
cares it doesn't matter anyway I'm into
seeing the establishment burn like
that's fine to return a 10 type of power
to the people
I mean that wholeheartedly yeah but like
when you say burn the simulation down
well yeah because I don't believe I
don't believe the simulation like how
Elon believes it like in his videos I
mean that they've put a organ organic
organism simulation on top of our base
reality and that should go because it's
it's stripping us of uh our free will
you say in a video game but I just want
to point out like if maybe we are in a
video if it was possible okay look if it
was possible to set a fire to the code
that is the universe you know we'd be in
very serious trouble if someone could
like I'm going like burning on the
simulation is a figurative statement
that just means like you know it depends
how you view the simulation yeah you
know maybe the Large Hadron Collider is
a way to burn down a type of simulation
it'd be funny if the Large Hadron
Collider is like there's a bunch of
global Elites who genuinely believe
we're in a simulation and they're trying
to like manipulate code they're trying
to like like I mean that may be a way to
view it it's like the code of the
universe they're trying to manipulate
it's possible if you have the people
who've opened up portal who said they've
been with portals who bring in beasts
through other dimensions so I don't know
I I've heard some crazy Ayahuasca
stories yeah right and how much of that
is in their minds and how much is like
is that really Beyond the Veil or
whatever do you think there's a layer to
a lot of this
um a bigger kind of abuse stuff when it
comes to the spiritual war that's
happening out there because we know
there's people like uh Brina brovich
that do Spirit cooking we know that
there's a lot of rituals we know that
there's a lot of also individuals that
believe in in kind of a satanic order
have you seen anything uh like this from
your line of work or have anything to to
kind of add to that
I have not so I don't really just by
happenstance it's not that I don't
haven't tried or actively tried or not
tried I know individuals who have
experienced abuse with some of that but
uh but I haven't served any survivors
specifically that have faced that type
of abuse I think um
the Survivor that actually had had the
organization that saved my life Eve's
Angels kind of delves into some of that
there's there's some survivors that I
know like Rose McGowan kind of comes
from a darker childhood we're friends
um
but it seems like almost everything it's
evil yes do I think there's um something
like a deeper energetic spiritual war to
all of this which of course I I think
there is I think yes
as I get older things start to feel more
like demonic yeah and and like holy or
light when I was younger I I genuinely
was like there's no such thing as good
or evil there's just people of different
perspectives and Views and then I get
older I learn more I travel more I've
been to other countries and then I'm
just like reading these stories and I
was like these people are evil and and
it's it's it may be hard to understand
because it oversimplifies
but I think you get old enough and you
look at the behaviors of certain
individuals and you realize there is
nothing pure there is just Mal intent it
is a Darkness within them this is why
individuals like you know Jeffrey
Epstein and Bill Gates were connected
together because they believed that
there was too many people on this Earth
and that they were all both eugenesis
they all believed in of course having
um you know a class of individuals
Epstein was doing a lot of human
experimentation and a lot of scientific
projects especially when it came to him
cloning a large portion of of the earth
a lot of weird stuff was going on yes he
had
um he had one of his scientific
experiments that we actually know about
was that he was trying to get as many
women as he could so he could impregnate
them at the same time in order to spread
his genes everywhere so that's that's
literally what these people are up to
that's literally some of the thinking
that goes into it some people say it's
because they just have too much money
too much power too much control and they
just do things in order to get some kind
of feeling and effect from it because
everything is meaningless to them or
some people say that they've been
overcome and and taken over by larger
spiritual demonic forces that they're
acting on beheads of and they've been
kind of hijacked by them and they're
kind of doing their bidding so whatever
you may believe on this particular topic
I think there's a reason that they do
have a lot of these kind of uh
ceremonies a lot of these kind of uh
larger actions a lot of the times
bragging about a lot of the stuff they
do in plain sight
um I I think there's you know I could go
further down the rabbit hole but I don't
want to do that on this show but it gets
the rabbit hole gets a lot deeper than
it goes here yes there's a few things
that um brought me back to believing in
God years ago but one of those things
was when the Epstein news broke I was
like this is the most evil thing that I
could imagine like in my time
um with the kids and stuff that if
there's something that evil there must
be a counter a good you know a balance
that because in nature I see balance I
see you know in the seasons Alone
um so that was like a big moment for me
when I remember it was like a beautiful
day too and I was just like it was so it
became so dark when I really went down
that rabbit hole and investigating that
story so I think I think it happened for
a lot of people I think it really uh I
think that story broke a lot of people
and I think that's why we sort of Saw
and I understand why I mean it's
devastating it's horrific on a scale
unimaginable but I think that's that
sort of breaking of the mind is sort of
why a lot of folks
went down a roll of following
um
I don't want to get you trouble queuing
on yeah they like went down that because
they're brain broken they're like if
that isn't true you know if that
happened then what else is happening you
know one of the things and I know Luke
will understand this like Epstein was
really bad the United States government
will bomb
millions of children and keep Wars going
you know kill kill Millions for a
paycheck
so I mean this Epstein absolutely
horrible many many survivors globally
many that we will never know their names
think about what what our own government
does as far as I consider our government
like a serial killer Well it's worse
yeah I mean on a massive scale right and
we fund it because I always think of
Tuskegee you know and stuff like that
just refunded the thousands Associated
the thousands of survivors of the UN
globally at the hands of the UN you know
child exploitation sexual exploitation
and we fund them 22 humans and seven
percent sorry it seems like humans at
scale become sociopathic yeah I mean
look the U.S certainly is better than
basically everything else we've seen
throughout history we've done tremendous
in this country for advancing civil
rights yes you know different groups and
uh we have a great degree of Freedom
that many countries have never had but
that's that's thanks to the initial seed
planted of this country yeah you look at
all you mentions Tuskegee MK Ultra I
mean there's a lot
aren't we oh yeah it's bad aren't humans
messy but but you look at Stalin you
look at communists you know uh I wonder
if it's powerful socio sociopaths rise
to power and and and just like I
shouldn't say sociopaths people have no
empathy in general people who just don't
care about you who view themselves as
God rise to power and then cause Mass
harm or is it just that when the machine
of humans collectivizes and becomes too
big they just have tremendous power that
causes harm in various ways without
accountability and without care right
it's probably both like I think I
mentioned this when Bryson was on but we
talked about Unit 731 with Japan what
they did to people which is I'll give
you an example they would take someone
and stick their arm through a hole into
Sub-Zero weather so their arm would
freeze while they were still alive
inside then they would pull their Frozen
arm in and shatter it with a hammer yes
I believe Vivid section is something I
also did where they would open up
someone watch the organs work and then
make them eat themselves but uh what I
was gonna say is there are people in
there who probably just part of the
system who get chewed up on both sides
obviously but then there are people in
charge like I forget his name but he
ended up becoming like a giant uh CEO of
a big pharmaceutical company I forget
what it was at this point but it became
a huge one in Japan so I think there's a
mixture of greed with those people the
power and then they just have a lot of
people that they um they can control
it's crazy stuff man oh it's evil Angela
mcgirdle from the libertarian party put
up a Super Chat
yeah she gave you a shout out did she
yeah yeah that's one of my besties oh
that's awesome shout out to you Angela
and actually shout out to my cousin
Nathan he's a big fan of yours Tim sick
all right on he saw me on the last I
should tell you guys the story
um he saw me on the last episode and he
didn't know anything about any of this
whole thing
and um we were at his mother's funeral
and he's rather shy and we haven't
talked a lot but we don't have any beef
we just don't talk a lot he's a pretty
shy person and
um it was at his mother's funeral
unfortunately she passed away
and the first thing I think he's ever
really said to me that was like
he was like cyan Scion tube cast that
was weird I was like yeah that was weird
but it was kind of cute because we had a
bonding moment on such a rough day yeah
and um so yeah that's been one thing
that's kind of been weird about stepping
forward is like now my family
knows everything and uh but look let's
I'm sorry you should you should finish
the thought sorry no you're good I was
about to ramble and you probably saved
me okay
actually Tim but let's talk about Elon
and Twitter before we go because folks
might not know that story and it's well
it's awesome which one what happened
Let's uh the fact that I worked my butt
off for two years to get to to get
Twitter to make changes and begged and
begged and I did it all by myself with
no government help and no money and no
support from any organization I did it
all on my own and got the attention of
Elon Musk who purchased the platform and
then made the issued priority number one
I think that's a good story did you have
Silence from the previous Twitter
Administration uh Jack Dorsey did help
me out um a little bit but it wasn't
enough yeah and um yeah Elon Musk Elon
Musk has been absolutely incredible he's
been gracious he's been kind he's gone
above and beyond to support me and to
implement new suggestions and I don't
know what this new hit piece is about
but uh I can just assume it's in the
least favorable light and I don't
remember them doing such deep
investigative journalism while I was out
here screaming for the past two years
with two plus years actually but it was
really learning about the story of John
no one and John Doe two that uh sort of
sent me on that Crusade and I'm so
grateful to Elon Musk for even listening
to me
um and starting to implement some
changes yeah so yeah right on you you
mentioned Q I wanted I wanted to pull up
this story from the Salt Lake Tribune
these Utah Brothers want the Supreme
Court to remove Joe Biden from the White
House and reinstate Donald Trump the U.S
Supreme Court could decide on Friday
whether or not to hear a long shot
lawsuit that alleges members of Congress
broke their oath of office by certifying
the 2020 presidential election now
I'm sorry if this comes off as dismissed
dismissive
but long shot is an understatement not
because I'm not making an argument on
the merits I always think that uh merits
should be heard out and sometimes that
means summary dismissal sometimes it
means Discovery sometimes it means
summary judgment whatever
um but the idea that what what are we
looking at 300 the idea that 387 members
of Congress
the President and Vice President would
be removed by the Supreme Court is just
so far-fetched
I I do not believe there is a reality in
which that could happen Okay obviously
if there's infinite realities it happens
infinite number of times but I'm just
like as much as it I mean I I wish
how amazing would it be if I come Monday
and Supreme Court's like we're gonna
hear the lawsuit and then they bang the
gamble like you're right Congress
dismissed president gone and then we
have no Congress and we have no
executive branch that's pretty good one
can only dream right right right I think
anything's possible I don't know anymore
the last five years have proven to me
that literally anything's possible but
this does seem like an evolution a lot
of the Q stuff where people I had
friends I would go over their house and
it'd be like all these people have died
and I think they're you know in
Guantanamo and I'm like I don't know
about that dude but maybe well I don't
trust these news outlets like the Salt
Lake Tribune says it's making
Acquisitions of Fraud and all that stuff
maybe I just don't believe them yeah
because I think there is actual grounds
for a lawsuit based on procedural
elements of the 2020 election that is to
say is universal mail-in voting
constitutional some of these questions
never got resolved in many states Texas
V Pennsylvania never even got hurt I
think it was Texas beef Pennsylvania was
the major lawsuit and the Supreme Court
refused to hear it so there never even
was an argument about whether or not
anything that was going on was
constitutional I think the court should
hear that if that is the basis for this
I certainly don't see a reality in which
for 300 nearly the entirety of Congress
is removed I think I think 75 of this
country would be in favor of that isn't
that kind of crazy approval for Congress
is so low that if they probably if they
held like a like a like a Convention of
states and a referendum on like just
removing and restarting Congress I bet
it would pass probably so I've seen a
lot of people cheer the last few days
which is exciting in terms of Kevin
macarthy speaker right yeah and I see
people I'm friends with who disagree
with me on certain things politically
but we can all enjoy that because it's
just uh stalling a place that I think
seeks to uh harm us anyway well at 10
o'clock they are going to reconvene in
the house and then Kevin McCarthy's
claiming he's going to win so we'll see
but I I can say this whatever ends up
happening with the Brunson thing I'm
gonna go ahead and bet probably nothing
I think the Supreme Court will not hear
it if they do I will be very surprised
but regardless of what you think about
this case
I think it's fair to say that there is
something deeply wrong with this country
and that and that and that we all
recognize it whether the left recognizes
it or the right does the establishment
there is something deeply wrong and what
that solution is
you'd think would be outrageous of
grievances through a lawsuit but it
seems like none of these things ever
have an impact and the argument from the
machine is always they're meritless and
it's just like come on man you know as
you wrote about with the Kerry Lake
stuff they they the judge ruled against
Kerry Lake she's appealing but there
there was evidence presented that needs
to be accounted for that is to say that
why were the tabulators rejecting
ballots because they were 19-inch images
on 20-inch paper so they couldn't go
through that creates a problem and you
can't just be like oh don't worry they
dropped it in a Ballot Box and got
counted later and it's like okay so
let's have a conversation about how at
was it 72 locations yeah someone changed
the images on these printers yep like
that there's they've just started
talking about on the on the second day
of trial exactly and they denied it
happen in the first day right so if the
end result is that there was one guy who
went around pressing the buttons lock
him up but they just ignore it that's
the problem even the courtroom couldn't
run things technically like like
proficient it's like if a small closed
system like a courtroom couldn't even
get like HDMI cables right what makes
you think all these elections wait wait
you guys still have faith in government
you think they're going to do something
good for you it's like I'm trying to I
know I don't have faith in the
government but it's like I'm trying to
keep faith in people but I'm having I'm
losing faith in people because I even
think if we remove the government like I
was saying to you about moving on to
yeah I know but but how because I'm
surrounded by people who truly worship
The Establishment well the argument I
would make is because
Psychopaths usually flee to uh the
biggest positions of power this is why
government is a vector for them and we
should always push push back against
them sorry I thought you were raising
your hand trying to say um I got a Tech
Deck
yeah practicing I usually talk with my
left so I'm using my right I agree but
but yeah the other thing about that
trial that was upsetting is like I was
also kind of having flashbacks to the
the summer of the riots because even if
you have evidence even if they show it
in court a whole country could look at
it together and half of them could just
not believe the evidence like even if
it's a video showing these things not
working people be like nah don't believe
it and it's like the the problem isn't
about the evidence it's not about the
the system really because now it's
really about just how we view our
ourselves and the world and I that's
where I'm like my pessimist nihilism is
starting to creep in because we're not
in a good place there totally I'm so
white pilled about the future is so well
because I was going to ask you like you
you talk to a lot of survivors yeah how
do you keep hope and when you hear all
these like dark stories
so there's evil and there's darkness in
the world
but there's also a lot of good in the
world and good and light and love will
win in the end and unfortunately not
everybody will make it there with us
not everybody gonna make it but it will
win in the end history has shown us this
repeatedly over and over again no matter
how dark Things Are
some will make it and good and light
love will win the end and it doesn't
stay bad forever I love that I want to I
want to ask one quick question before we
go to super chats I was just thinking
about this because I'm seeing people
chat my question is and it's not just
for you but for anyone can a woman
choose to be a sex worker at the request
of a man
can you say that again if a man asks a
woman to be a sex worker working for him
and she says yes
is is that a legitimate Choice she made
so the woman is over 18 and the man's
over 18 and are you is there an abortion
is there coercion like when you say ask
just just uh just we'll put plain and
simple a man goes to him and says I'm
going to create a cam business how would
you like to be one of my cam girls and
she says yes is that a legitimate choice
on her part
it just depends on it it depends on the
the entire breakdown of it so uh and by
the way every there everyone's gonna
have an opinion on this and many people
won't agree with me
um I believe that an individual can be a
willing adult Entertainer
um but that would have to come from
inside the individual that wants to be a
willing adult Entertainer
um as far as someone asking like if you
said to me hey Eliza I um need an extra
host on the show will you come be a host
on the show I could then choose but I if
even if I didn't ask you to be a host on
the show then I would still be choosing
to be a host on the show does that mean
I don't know so so each situation is
going to be different so if coercion if
Force product coercions involved it's
human trafficking if it's not involved
then it's nice even if it's just having
you host a show
no I'm sorry I wasn't trying to mix the
two with the caming no well so that
would only be labor trafficking if you
use forceparter coercion to get me to
work for you for free and you kept the
money
so for free so if you were free or a
little bit of a pay so this is what I
was getting to because someone someone
said in the chat regret is not rape or
something like that and others made the
point that if women chose to do a job
for someone the reasons they chose to do
the job aren't aren't material and so
here's what I was thinking I made a
tweet that got a lot of attention and I
thought it was hilarious I said if sex
work is work then can an employer
require his his staff to service him I
remember that tweet Tim and but it's but
it's but here's the problem I remember
that too it's a real question it's a
real question that they can't answer and
that's why they got mad because clearly
sex work is not work sex work is so no
means no and if an individual at any
time uh expresses that they're not
comfortable they should be allowed to go
or allowed to stop without uh I'm going
back to the original question just to be
clear
um but as far as coercion goes it would
depend and some folks identify so do I
think someone willingly do that work yes
so I think folks can be coerced into
doing the work yes so and that would be
up into the that would be up to the
individual doing it and in the case of a
Survivor stepping forward or victims
stepping forward we would let the Court
decide if it was coerced so was that
person able to leave at any time right
so anytime yes so would it be coercion
if I said Shane
move to from move from from California
to West Virginia where you will have
this job hosting this show
and don't worry we'll make sure you have
a place to live and if Shane was like
man it's gonna be really hard for me to
move don't worry man we'll take care of
you then he gets here and I say I want
you to take the garbage out now
otherwise I'm I'm firing you is that
coercion
it would depend on the nature I mean
there's a lot of variables there I don't
know was that part of his job that you
agreed on yeah
this is my point if if if you go to a
person who lives in Canada and say move
to the United States yes you'll be here
on a work visa we'll pay you x amount of
dollars we'll give you a place to live
and you will do job a yes then they
arrive and you say you know what we also
want you to take the garbage out from
now on and they say hey man I didn't
agree to do the garbage well if you
don't do it I'm I'm firing you you can't
but if you fire me how am I going to get
back to my home country well that's too
bad you should have thought of that like
is that coercion are they holding the
papers are they restricting them from
walking out the door no you can leave
good luck getting a plane back to Canada
though and finding a place to live once
you go back to your country is that
coercion
maybe you lured them there under false
pretenses but I would let the courts
decide coercion I don't to me that
doesn't sound coercive if it is coerced
it is coercion in a way but not in the
way of human trafficking what if a guy
said to a woman come work for me and be
the host of a show yeah we'll pay you
then she gets here and they say as part
of your job you'll be performing sex
acts and she goes no well then you can
get out you're fired and is that
coercion yes so so right this is my
point the only difference is the action
if the action is something like physical
labor you say well maybe it's for the
Court decide if it's sexual hands down
it is that's my point sex work is not
work sex work is clearly distinct sex
works is clearly its own category well
that would also possibly followed her
sexual harassment that would be a couple
different uh crimes but I'm not gonna
you this is the point I was making the
left when they come out and say sex work
is work they are basically saying that
whether you are performing a sex act or
taking out the garbage you're doing
you're doing work
and then that's why I ask that question
no that's not true because sex is
clearly in a specific protected category
I mean like access of sexual nature that
taking out the garbage is not you go to
a lawyer and you say I want you to take
it out your garbage if they say no you
can fire them you cannot go to a lawyer
and say I want you to start performing
gratification on another person that's
illegal so so as much as many of these
leftists try to make that argument it's
just not the case and that's why I agree
with you telling someone to come out for
a job that's like juggling bowling pins
then when they get there you say you
also got to clean the floors and they
say no well then you're fired yeah well
too bad you got fired but if if they say
come out here to juggle bowling pins
once they get there they say now you've
got to perform sex acts okay now you're
into that trafficking like you're in
that coercion territory happens a lot
more than you'd think actually
the switch up happens pretty quickly too
but it's a blink of an eye and
especially when you're scared it's hard
to just uh walk away it's interesting
that it's a more it's a like that view
is more conservative the the leftist
progressive view tends to be that sex
work is just work and who cares so
unless and until you advocate for that
to be applied to the labor market and
then all of a sudden the 50 year old fat
slob has the right to incorporate in his
smoothie making position sexual
gratification well it's just work
that was that was kind of my point like
if you think it is just work and I don't
then why couldn't an employer say job
description for store clerk ringing up
the cheeseburgers handing out the bags
and giving [ __ ]
speaking of uh conservative folks should
go to my Twitter account and check out
my statement my statement's probably the
most Savage thing you'll read this year
directed at the right well all right but
we're going to read some super chats so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com no
members only show tonight it's Friday
but we do have a massive library of
members only content uncensored not so
family friendly and we really do
appreciate your support because with
your support as members we are building
a lot of really awesome stuff notably
physical locations currently underway
we're going to be launching a
skateboarding show not just
skateboarding more than that scooting
blading biking Etc and uh the goal is to
have cultural influence to inspire
people to make the world a better place
long story short protect the family
individual responsibility and freedoms
molon labe things like that let's read
the great treasure says if you want to
be traditional men women need to be
traditional also hmm I think that there
is a um
I I saw that gender bell curve where
they saw it's bimodal like there's some
overlap in the middle and that's how I
feel I am totally fine with women having
jobs I'm totally fine with men being
stay home dads but I think that it's
like we don't want the absolutes we
don't want a complete inversion where
men stop working and become effeminate
and women become overly masculine
because that destabilizes we want people
to be free so not as rigid as things
were 100 years ago but we still do want
to recognize in my opinion the
differences between males and females
masculine Indian femininity yeah to a
great degree yeah yep do I still get to
keep my hair short that's the question
yes do I get to keep my hair short of
course all right here we go here we're
gonna get into the contentious nature of
those some love take some hate
David Robinson says Tim defending Andrew
Tate just because Tate sounds like Luke
on certain topics is very tribal just
because the system doesn't like you
doesn't mean you're good Eliza you are
stronger than most Alphas like Tate I am
not here to defend or condemn Andrew
Tate I've not seen evidence other than
accusations
that there you go right so I don't know
what else I'm supposed to say it's
possible that they smeared him like they
smeared Julian Assange it's also
possible that when he talked on podcasts
about having women fly out to perform on
cams there was something dark statement
Tim you should read my statement because
you haven't had that same energy about
the Epstein Epstein it's like all
oh who call co-conspirators all
co-conspirators should be held
accountable but now it's like oh let's
pause let's wait but what do you mean
like with Epstein we had transcripts
released there's more stuff being
released why don't you look into it
you've got to make a decision right
right right that's an energy I've I've
seen videos of Andrew Tate yeah it's
been a month not it's been it's been
three weeks the Epstein stuff's been a
few years 11 13 30.
that we know about the circum the
circumstantial evidence along with the
hard evidence when it comes to Epstein
when it comes to the outright admissions
of some of the people associated with
them is very very different from it's
been three weeks and Andrew Tate just
got arrested you know what I mean okay
so we'll see we'll see if the energy
stays the same yeah I mean I've outright
said there's videos of Andrew Tate
saying he had women working for him just
because they loved him then he had women
working for him because they wanted
money and then she threw up in his in
his apartment he said I'm not going to
pay you so she goes to the cops claiming
you hit her like there's a lot to the
things he said if you've seen these
videos and they're the what the way the
left has described it is he went on he
there's like an hour's worth of him
admitting to committing crimes and it's
like yeah there's an hour's worth of him
admitting to being kind of like a dick
in a lot of ways but it's been three
weeks so I'm not from the left and well
I know I'm saying that's that's what
they were posting and I've also
advocated for Julian Assange I said in
front of the doj at uh you know free
Assange rally in October and spoke I was
a speaker at the Assange rally so it's
not like I'm just go down every like
rabbit hole that somebody's been accused
and and do that deal but I think that
um
I think this is worth looking at
Ace Blackstar says unlike Epstein Andrew
doesn't have his fingers in the
government of many countries to cover up
for Epstein so I will not believe or
even support you until he's proven
guilty stop calling him an abuser
it goes both ways we're actually getting
a decent uh debate here I appreciate it
you guys like you don't got to agree
with me but I uh I appreciate you guys
uh chatting
yeah look at that 22 000 50 50 on smash
the like button right there it's 53 and
47 for 22 000 votes it's a lot I mean
it's it's usually like two-thirds so
it's skewing slightly towards I have not
smashed the like button but uh 84 said
they believe they did not believe Angie
Tate was guilty and that's not just
saying they think he's innocent it's
that many people are saying show me the
evidence correct right right there's
there's give it a little time there's a
lot with Epstein there's a lot with
Epstein we'll give it a little time
absolutely um and like I said earlier if
he's if he actually did these things
then he needs to be locked up yeah and I
hope I'm wrong every single time and
like we were saying before I hope I'm
wrong every single time sorry Luke no no
and I think the media narrative also
matters here because a lot of the times
the media was running protection for uh
Epstein they were uh here they're like
running about pizza box stories they're
running fake news they're discrediting
themselves based on stuff so this is why
automatically people jump to this okay
but I'm not from the media
been smeared by the media in the last
month they hate me the left doesn't like
I'm just explaining some of the thinking
of what's going on and I understand
that's why I'm here as a peaceful uh
maybe middle person to be like hey folks
I'm from your I don't want to say side
but you folks rock with me you know I'm
the real deal so if I'm saying let's
take a deeper look hopefully that
carries a little bit more weight with
people that might have normally been a
little bit more skeptical yeah but the
general idea I think Luke it's a real
good example the pizza box story yes was
completely false false and insane and so
right away the whole narrative has
launched off of a false premise it's
just let me read this right here yeah
Rhys Mendocino says I'm in no way with
Andrew Tate but we need to recognize
that most of the boys who flock to him
are a result of boys and men who are
hurting from a collapsing culture and
awful dating Market we need to do better
for them well put yeah
well put well said
yep yep all right Charlie Harris says
what crimes has Tate been formally
charged with it's a matter of public
record so there's no reason not to say
it over the air I don't think he's been
publicly charged he's being investigated
for being a lover boy
um rape and money laundering that that's
what we know he's being investigated the
whole false narrative around the pizza
box thing was so annoying because he has
a compound in Romania they don't need to
know he's there they know he's there and
he has a massive compound but the fake
news also discredits the legitimacy of
this story so the corporate media just
by running fake news does so much
Injustice to all of this well they did
yeah they've done the same thing to me
they did the same thing to me with Elon
Musk they did the same thing to Tim
they've done it I mean they've done it
to you they've done it to all of us and
it sucks
and they did it to Brett Kavanaugh if
you remember what happened to him I
don't know if you remember that story or
or your response to how that was going
down sure I mean I I Believe In Due
Process I think that that and I've
always I've said that since the
beginning if folks want to put in due
process into my Twitter search bar I say
I believe the survivors that I serve and
I explain to every Survivor that I serve
due process you can't just believe every
single story so I understand folks being
skeptical that's cool
um so I go ahead Raymond g Stanley Jr in
reference to the Philadelphia train
story says drop kick him Tim drop kick
him I said uh I would drop kick the dude
if I saw a guy jumping up a woman I
would I I'd jump on him like if he was
standing up I would run up and drop kick
and I'd like I can't I don't know man
I've had a lot of people
base like everybody seems to be of this
mindset that everyone else is going to
be like them and so they'll say things
like you wouldn't do that you wouldn't
like don't project your views onto me
like
there's a video I went on Tucker because
of this because antifa got my face and
started swinging at me and I I clenched
my teeth tight my abs and I leaned
forward you can watch me do it I I get I
get I get angry especially when people
get in my face
and I I just I don't know it's the kind
of person I am and I think too
I don't know you you get screwed with
enough in places like the south side of
Chicago or traveling around the world
where trust me when I say like I
probably I would I would drop kick the
guy I don't even want to say probably I
I probably just lose it I'd probably
black out and be like I don't remember
what happened I just went on the guy I
know this is totally unrelated but I
just want to say something I just want
to let everybody know I'm working on
this case for free I serve all the
survivors that I serve the public
survivors for free I get no money from
this nobody's paying me to be here
nobody's paying me to say anything I got
no money from the Twitter uh advocating
for the Twitter survivors of Twitter I
did all that work for free
um everything I do I do for free and
usually lose money so I just want to say
that because I know people are going to
say a thing like I'm in this for money
I'm literally not in this for money and
I actually lose money doing this work
Giovanni lycea says can you elaborate on
what the machine is the establishment
it's a reference to the like you know
Rage Against the Machine of course they
rage on behalf of the machine these days
but uh the machine is the establishment
the control it is you want to talk about
the cathedral the cathedral yeah the
cathedral yeah but a lot of people don't
yes of course the cathedral darling yes
no the cathedral uh is gonna be like
your school system starts at the school
um by what would you call it Luke like
not brainwashing but sort of
indoctrinating the young children then
it goes up to up through the government
schools to the universities then it goes
to corporate journalism and then to the
government
good Cathedral yeah sort of but
basically the machine is just like
imagine this giant Factory where it
Hollywood and big Tech in there too
controls production it controls what
you're allowed to say it's where all the
establishment establishment people are
it's it's it's robotic it's duplicitous
it's it's unempathetic
and the opposite of that is freedom yes
so you so imagine that's a big Factory
inside you wear a jumpsuit you do as
you're told but there's food square and
you know and you and you keep your mouth
shut you do it you do you're not allowed
to talk about certain ideas you do your
job and then outside in the wilderness
is freedom where uh figure it out
that's it I prefer dangerous Freedom
over peaceful slavery
every time the backlash every time every
time obsessed I
obsessed with that
it's
I think it's the best way for it gives
me life let's read this one the
backlight says in 1993 I very publicly
opposed the progressive assault on men
masculinity marriage and family The
Seattle Times almost destroyed me men
turned to mgtow to strike Atlas Shrug
style mgtow is men going their own way
but I'm not I don't I'm not going to
pretend to know everything about what
mgtow is but uh correct me if I'm wrong
my understanding is it's like men just
living solitary lives and just going
their own way and either like being
alone or you know just avoiding
relationships and stuff I don't know
about mgtow I think one of the problems
is Society for like it's created this
this very hard imbalance in the
relationship between men and women and I
feel like a lot of it's on purpose
malthusianism or whatever like this this
idea that
you know I'll put it this way
abortion
child castration
you know hormones in the water all of
these things result in lower population
is that on purpose
for you to decide I think it's just very
interesting that there's powerful
prominent Elites that are going around
saying we got to reduce population and
then all of these ales of society which
are doing just that yeah
let's grab some more Super chats
what do we got here
Mundo Mars says I used to be pro-abort
because I thought people have common
sense but when I heard a girl say that
her birth control is abortion I lost all
hopes in humanity by the way may I
support for my YouTube channel Mundo
Mars keep up the good work appreciate
the Super Chat
all right
what was that what was that
um
um Super Chat
derpington says the comment that I think
Ian said even the cops don't protect you
yeah they're literally not required to
an Arco tyranny in action maybe that was
Luke who said the cops don't protect you
right yeah there's many documented cases
including uh the Joe lazito story which
is absolutely crazy he's a friend of
mine look up we are changed Joe lizito
be prepared to be mind blown I was
thinking Uvaldi
all right part-time Doge says guys John
Bolton thinks he would be a viable 24
candidate he also may have announced on
a British show a little confused if he
did or didn't he did he's gonna get
Negative votes like somehow it's just
like negative three or all the suicidal
people who want World War III are gonna
vote for him and then uh he's probably
gonna become president of the United
States so the long-term game plan is to
make everyone depressed so they're
suicidal and they're all going to vote
for John Bolton John Bolton's going to
kill us by starting world war three so
wow yeah it's like debunk you know we
should do that sounds horrible I got it
I got an idea
yo okay hear me out you guys have seen
Twilight Zone right yes remember the one
with the guy with the glasses and the
books
okay here's what happens John Bolton
becomes president declares war he's he's
riding in the bomber flying over Iran
and they just bomb everything and then
there's just explosions all over the
planet then he's walking through the
rubble of Tehran and then he smiles and
he goes well and then he leans down to
pick up you know uh welcome to Tehran
sign his glasses fall up and shatter and
then he goes no it was time now it was
you guys know that one right you've
never seen that one oh come on this
whole image the the world ends and this
guy just wants to read books and then
when he reaches down to pick up a book
his glasses fall off and break and now
he can't read books and it's like the
apocalypse so like John Bolton in the
rubble of Iran in the world is destroyed
it was time now
sorry who would John Bolton run with who
runs on that ticket Satan
so like Jeffrey Dahmer okay okay Jeffrey
Thomas no no but in all seriousness like
who would run a Bolton ticket is it a
bush Elaine Maxwell
Crenshaw I think that's what he said oh
yeah yeah yeah this morning was Crenshaw
open this Cheney yeah I think you're
right I think Cheney actually yeah yeah
they lose a bumper sticker let's let's
bomb the Middle East again like we
looked in The Ballot Box and not only
were there no ballots in there but it
was a void a rip in the time space
continues it's spitting out ballots for
us I don't know how this is happening
bouts are coming out of the box
where are we got uh Christian wolf says
one I'd make Frank castle look like a
Boy Scout that's in reference to the one
if you would sacrifice yourself to save
the woman Frank Castle if you don't know
is the Punisher yeah I think the
Punisher I love the Punisher stories I
mean
it's it's a fantasy but let's be real
but man there's something satisfying
about Justice have you guys ever seen um
law-abiding citizen nope
Gerard Butler
he's at home when some burglars break
into his house crack him over the head
rape his wife
kill I think they kill his wife and
daughter and then he lives
and then let's just say he gets revenge
on everyone
Unfortunately they spiked the ending
I'll I'll spoil the movie because it's
old but apparently the ending was
supposed to be like
so years later he tracks down the guy
and he vivisects him and films it and
slowly slowly ends it's insane he
intentionally gets arrested because he
planned this whole thing and then from
and then he murders his his cellmate to
get put into the special cell that he
already tunneled through so he can
freely move about committing crimes and
going after the prosecutors going after
the system that refused to get Justice
they cut a deal with with these guys and
then he gets mad and apparently the
ending was supposed to be him destroying
the city and getting revenge but um the
other guy what was his name Jamie Foxx I
guess didn't want that that's a bad
ending is a bad guy winning so he
ultimately loses in the end and it's not
as satisfying because there's something
just very punisher-esque about him being
like my family was killed in the system
let these guys go free
so I I it's a good movie you know it's
good
Darius Harvey says I think the believe
all women narrative really hurt true
abused victims no one wants to stick
their neck out anymore um
I agree but how did Christine blasey
Ford right but how do we she lied about
everything
I believe so how do we look listen to uh
some folks that maybe aren't
um I don't know credible but and then
like you can't discredit all survivors
just because or some individuals that
step forward or are accusers you can't
discredit everyone because of a few bad
experiences I mean we've been saying the
same raggedy there's no discredit
but I believe the survivors I serve and
I believe in due process
folks aren't advocate
folks we're at the Advocates you would
also believe the survivors you serve and
also explain you go into these I mean
the situations with skepticism first
like do you have to say no to certain
people when they come to you I don't
know I I don't have room to be
everyone's Advocate right especially
everyone that asks right um there are
some cases that I'm probably better
suited to serve yeah
um for instance this case because I'm
under I understand now what it's like to
have my life destroyed by the corporate
press by the public by the bot Farm you
know that's attacking
um I understand the Left Right Dynamic
um that's why I'm well suited to be an
advocate in this way yeah here in this
case I'm worried because I find myself
doing all the time too I lead with
skepticism now but almost everything
which is an unhealthy place I think
transparency okay you know the more
people see that does a Survivor have to
give to gain Trust of people I would say
as as much as possible unfortunately
because people skepticism if a dude came
to me and said that
some guy robbed him help me I'd say okay
I'd call the police and say I got a guy
who's been robbed
am I going to believe 100 that he's
telling the truth it's like no but we'll
pursue
you know the allegations because that's
the that's fine but why is the first gut
instinct for people to go online and
talk trash
what do you mean well okay it's not for
every person depends on the way they're
talking trash because there's trolls
yeah just talk trash and there's other
people who are also like the um but they
troll everything they troll everything
that's true that's true it's just it
makes it really difficult for survivors
to step forward and I'm always trying to
think of how we can make that a little
bit easier I I don't know if you can and
okay yeah without infringing on free
yeah you're right it's just
we we protect the innocent and and
protecting the innocent means
let's talk about mattress girl remember
mattress girl if you walk into the
mattress yeah and she was the abuser and
she got
everything handed to her Society abused
the guy that she abused the victim was
beaten down by the machine so basically
the long story I don't know that case so
I can't speak on it woman walks around
with a mattress around Columbia uh was
it Columbia I think claiming that she
was raped it turns out she was begging
the guy to be with her and the guy
didn't want to be with her based on
messages that got released in a lawsuit
the school threw him under the bus his
life his life was uh I don't know if it
was destroyed but severely he acted out
of school I think and like expelled and
then she got the cover of magazines the
machine propped her up and protected her
and she was the abuser Christine blasey
Ford she claimed that she was too scared
to fly and then they asked her in the
hearing like didn't you fly like this
point she was yes did you fly here yes
and she goes I'm so scared about because
because 35 years ago I was hoping I have
two doors on my house and then it was
like that's because she's airbn being
another portion of her house like this
woman went in front of the country and
and and then you had what was her name
sweatnik where she claimed that Brett
Kavanaugh was part of gang rape college
parties where they would line up outside
the door and and and with kidnapped
women who were drugged and so the issue
is
you come out and you make an accusation
I say we do our preliminary
investigation but we're not here if Luke
came to me and said Shane punched him in
the face it's like well why would I
instantly believe something bad about
[ __ ] about Shane but Tim people don't I
wouldn't snitch
together yeah I don't believe I'm a
Survivor and I've never said anything
about whom because I'm not legally
Michael Michael Tracy recently did a
threat about this
um
course I saw yeah and I know why that
was I was really embarrassed for him
because it wasn't factual I wish she'd
done a better job for him well Well here
here's the thing I would say for you in
that regard is you've come out talked
about your experiences advocated to help
people and you've not actually targeted
another person I think you've actually
kept that private because I'm not
legally I'm not legally able to speak
about it that's why and there's a
detriment that's a multiple multiple
journalists but it's kind of like Okay
but well what I have done is I had the
organization that saved my life on
Twitter spaces speaking about that what
that process was like saving my life
um going through a play-by-play but the
organization now has come out and said
that I've given a really decent timeline
of everything that I did with that the
safe house that I went to I talked about
the safe gave the name of the safe house
that I went to so the organization that
saved my life was Eve's angels in
Chicago they had multiple locations at
the time Annie is on Twitter and I went
to you know refuge for women in Kentucky
you don't go you know that was the safe
house that I went to that was where they
sent me so why would you come out and
say all that and I understand skepticism
that's fine but what what you have to
look at incentive what would the
incentive be for me to come out and say
that I'm a Survivor take no money for
any of it I'm not selling anything oh
yeah but there's no incentive okay like
I sure could if they wanted sure so
let's say like hypothetically it is made
up what's my biggest win so far in
public getting Twitter to address child
sexual abuse material make it a top
priority well that's why I'm saying like
what where's the win where's the win
there like what's the big win or what
would the big gain be I'm not asking an
abuser for money or not asking people
for money this is why when it comes to
your story it's like oh the only thing
you're doing is getting Twitter to fix
the problem and and so there's there's
no conflict I'm advocating for survivors
when it comes to Andrew Tate it's people
know his show and have seen things they
like from him and then there's people
they never heard heard of accusing him
of doing something wrong so when it
comes to choosing to believe or not
believe person a I don't care if it's a
man woman person a comes to me person B
comes to me person a says person B does
bad thing I say well I I don't know that
I've not seen it you want me to
immediately join in your accusation
against person B now that's not easy to
do what we do for the legal system is we
say we heard you let's do our
preliminary inquiry to see if there's a
preponderance of evidence upon discovery
of one we will then move for an
investigation upon discovery of evidence
we will file for an indictment and then
we'll try to prove to a jury of our
peers this person did the things they
were sure no one really said that about
Maxwell no one said that about the
Epstein co-conspiracies I get what
you're saying because I agree with you
what do you mean like with with the
Epstein stuff we've gotten to the Hard
Evidence over a decade phase and people
demanded accountability and it went to
indictment and then Epstein died have
you seen in the EPS in the Epstein case
that you felt photos of Andrew Tate with
Elaine Maxwell and Virginia dufree and
then her saying yes because he did these
things I'm sorry sorry
it's too late and we're getting the
answers mixed up I apologize sorry there
was a lot there's a lot of testimony
especially uh uh how endowed Epstein
my brain was in the process
prince Andrew with Virginia and Maxwell
as well as flight Logs with all these
people and it's been it's been 10 years
and there's been look yeah the evidence
like some evidence comes out we'll do
another conversation and then we'll chop
it up then let's wait yeah witness
testimony is evidence but not proof and
so that's why I said if Andrew Tate did
these things he should be held
accountable when it comes to Epstein
we're at the point where we wanted a
legitimate investigation but we knew the
FBI was covering it up we knew that what
was it look they had documents they had
folders and binders and video
information and things like that that
were labeled and they never released
photos videos all of that cassette tapes
available
still trying to get the videos like this
is still in the process Epstein isn't
done yet folks I've said that once
already tonight the Epstein Maxwell case
is never done until it's done it's not
done
all right we should we should grab some
more Super chats because uh I gotta grab
at least a few more and we're gonna go a
little bit late
nazian says armed women make fewer
rapists fewer rapists reduce the need
for armed women unarmed women create
more rapists more rapists great armed
women there you go uh the wheel turns
Richard L says clearly the machine
attacked Tate
for what
what for what would they be attacking
him for it's interesting saying anything
that why was he banned from all these
platforms I'm not at Liberty to discuss
that now but further you will understand
later I I mean that's not good enough
for me okay go read every platform's
terms of service you are not allowed to
use Instagram or any other platform for
um human trafficking child sexual abuse
material child sexual exploitation or to
facilitate any crime around those things
it's Foster sesta signed in 2018 all the
platforms know this and he was doing
that I'm not saying he did that I'm
saying could you do you think maybe
there is another reason that he was
doing anything has an ex-playmate come
out and talked about uh her experience
yes she has you can pull up the article
of being contacted so I'm just saying
there might be more here that meets the
eye sure why don't we chill on the um
attack by the the only people that try
to get attacked by the machine like
Julian Assange and Edward Snowden and
they went after Jordan Peterson and the
Machine yeah they called him a Nazi they
tried getting them fired now they're
trying to put corporate press yes yes of
course they did and they tried and that
was universities forced them to go
through re-education I understand but
there's a difference between like
takeaways medical maybe I'm not
understanding the machine because this
isn't language that I use are you
talking so yes people are attacked by
the corporate press I have also this
month
and now the in they're trying to take
his medical license away from it yes
they are and I I said something about it
and and what and why for what reason are
they doing what do you think orwellian
is it not possible it's the same thing
with Andrew Tate sure it could be so I'm
not going to defend the machine until we
can see clear evidence so when we say
well maybe he got banned because he was
doing these awful things I'm like no no
no no no no no okay until you come out
and say like look at this message from
Instagram that's what got him banned I'm
gonna be like I I could also come out
and be like he was facilitating illegal
recipes he was advocating for smuggling
I could make up a million reasons as to
why he may have gotten banned and I
understand that so and I don't mind
skepticism that's fine it's it's not
even necessarily about skepticism it's
about like yo if this guy did it please
prove it to me so we can get him locked
up yes and if it's not the case then
that's the right stance I think that
that's a correct stance I think that
that's good I just um it's funny because
I thought I would come here and talk
about Elon Musk and Twitter the entire
time and literally we did not talk about
it we did a little bit we did yeah we
did for like 20 26 minutes I think no
you're good it's just a timer in my mind
I was like preparing the whole day for
that and now it's like Tate Fest
it's all good you know I never have this
type of stuff planned fully and I just
go with the flow yeah like the the
Epstein stuff everybody thought was
nonsense for a long time yeah and then
like ever you had Miami Herald you had
Mike cernovich and you had project
Veritas basically do this triple hit and
then all of a sudden it just damn broke
yes so uh my concern is
when we've seen things like blasi Ford
when we I should say Kavanaugh and and
Mattress girl and a bunch of other
stores I mean even Lena Dunham didn't
she she accused the DJ yep she falsely
accused the DJ and to individuals out
there that have been falsely accused I
want you to know I love you too I think
that that's heinous I think it's
horrible I have
um men in my life that are close dear
friends that have been falsely accused
they have explained to me in great
detail how it ruined their life
um and I don't take that lightly either
don't like either this one's critical
the Roz Rodriguez says as much as I want
to agree with quote awful guest I am
grateful timcast brings in people that I
don't 100 agree with uh or us watching
good job more please I'm I'm awful
guests could be well I'm talking about
shade clearly there's big Tate fans who
are they do they they're very very
critical but then there's also people
who are mad at me and they're very
defensive and supportive of you so it's
it's it's split but I think it's a good
conversation whether it's for or against
and Tim and I are cool just so everybody
knows we're gonna be cool I wonder if
I've wanted to hug him 10 times
throughout this well this is what I'm
saying like we gotta have like for the
people who disagree in our anger but
like we need to have that conversation
you know what I mean yes and we've got
your super chats too and like we're
having a conversation
so uh Angela McArdle says Eliza thank
you for your advocacy work it takes
courage to come forward and we
desperately need more courageous people
in today's culture
Angela so much she's Brave I need to
stop watching YouTube says I don't
believe Eliza that's okay
you and many people
hey
let's see Captain creativity says Tim I
think you described absurdism not
nihilism
I don't think I described absurdism yeah
I think absurdism is a little different
yeah
where are we let's grab we probably
overlap a little bit
if they're talking about Camus Philip R
says I'm a little behind but the reason
men cannot help abuse survivors is plain
and simple women victimized by men hate
men after that and then usually go
lesbian no joke I I don't think that's
true
that's definitely not always true that's
definitely not not always true no
I don't know it feels like a internet
Trope that's not real yeah that feels uh
there's something pushing like an Intel
line I feel like that's not a I'm not
gonna accuse you of being into and sell
or anything but that's uh it's a little
bit a little bit aggressive a little bit
ridiculous Daniel domasick says after
what they did to Kavanaugh I'm skeptical
yeah I mean I'm less with Kevin I was
very skeptical I mean he's a family guy
he's religious they had investigated him
before these accusations made no sense
with Andrew Tate he's got video clips of
him talking about bring out women to do
cam work and you're like okay well let's
take a look at this let's let's see what
this is all about I don't know about
detaining him for 30 days it's like
they need to publicly release some
evidence because this is a high profile
case you know what I mean my only ask is
not
believe a hundred percent
survivors until we can figure out what's
going on well maybe that's where I'm not
communicating well I'm not asking you to
believe me believe everything everything
everyone says but can we just not tear
down survivors and make it more
difficult for other survivors you know
miners survivors of Epstein like just
imagine how needed it was to get those
people off the street and committing
those crimes let's just not tear down
survivors in the process or accusers if
we don't like the word Survivor
um victim let's just not tear them down
until we figure out what's going on if
our goal is to protect the innocent then
we want to approach any accusation with
like
balance between the individuals involved
we don't want to insult the person
making accusation we don't want to
insert insult the person accused we want
to say okay I hear you let's figure this
out and figure out who's actually at
fault like who or I should say not who's
actually fault but is there is there a
crime here is there is there a slight
and that's what the courts are for yep
all right let's uh let's grab uh one
more here what is this Chris says Tim I
used to ascribe to your views of
positive nihilism but recently I became
more fundamentally theistic because now
I believe that man is not capable of
creating meaning in a substantial way
get Jay Dyer on the subject he could
represent the position well very cool
Ace Blackstar we'll read one more will
you call for the arrest of the accusers
if they are found to be lying and also
pay every cent you stole due to your
actions
I think it's referring to the people who
did I don't know about you because you
said you don't make money from it no but
the people who if they're found to be
lying should they pay restitution and
should they be arrested
like accusers
uh I believe that if someone makes a
false accusation of domestic violence
sexual assault
um anything like that I I do believe
that then it falls on the then it falls
on the fat yes arrested charged all that
stuff yes agreed and paid and pay uh
restitution as well yeah because I've
talked to people whose lives have also
been destroyed so I don't take false
accusations slightly right on my friends
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash the like button if you so choose
to become a member at timcast.com check
out our massive library of uncensored
members only shows Plus shows like Tales
from the inverted world and cast castle
at timcast.com we got a bunch of really
awesome stuff on the way so thank you
all so much for hanging out on this
Friday night and uh the debate was
fantastic so I do appreciate I
appreciate when people come in and
disagree we need it you know so I do
like it you can follow the show at
timcastirl on Instagram and Twitter and
wherever else you can follow timcast
news on Twitter you can follow me
personally at timcast allies do you want
to shout anything out Eliza blue at
e-l-i-z-a-b-l-e-u on Twitter and
um coming soon you myself Ian and some
other folks are going to be making an
announcement about an event in April oh
yeah
right on we're not it's not official to
launch it yet but there's something cool
coming up in Austin in April yeah it's
gonna be fun hopefully I'm invited uh oh
do you want to be invited I'd love to
see you there sure yeah
um anyway uh my website is Luke
uncensored.com we have a lot of members
on our members area we talk about a lot
of different stuff usually surrounding
Solutions projects we're doing an AMA
right now make sure to get your
questions in before I get overwhelmed
and can't answer all of them look
uncensored.com is where the conversation
is going to be thank you again so much
for having me and uh being on my website
so thanks awesome Yep Shane Cashman I'm
at Shane Cashman everywhere you can go
on timcast.com and check out the
inverted World stories and then recent
stories I've been doing and working on
some new ones right now and Eliza
grateful for your work and awesome to be
here with you I love you so much Shane
oh thanks a lot I'm like your biggest
fan thank you for supporting me so much
online I love you so much I think you
you have a creative mind and I told
Shane one time I said I firmly believe
that I had this feeling oh my God I said
I need to ask Shane to take my picture
and write an article because I have a
feeling his work will end up being
warhol-esque in a way where it's thank
you I'm serious thank you I don't know
how else to articulate it but I think um
you're really gifted and very talented
and I'm grateful we've been talking
about it right on yeah we got something
yeah we're gonna do a thing you know
what I think would be really cool and I
know you're trying to end the show but
I've had this Vision a little bit of you
coming out to the farm and really seeing
what my day-to-day life is like that's
the goal and it's totally different than
this Glam version yeah yeah that's the
goal that's I love doing stories like
that where I can just kind of do you
have any overalls do you have any boots
yeah do you have any slots in my past
life on a farm where I grew up do you
like cats I've got two okay I'm excited
uh you can bring your wife perfect yeah
it'd be great I was excited to hear from
uh like that wasn't a there were a few
prominent people who shouted out Shane's
story on yay and Kerry Lake
and um I was excited to hear it because
Shane emailed me a while ago and was
like Hey I'm a writer check this out and
I I like clicked one of the Articles and
I couldn't stop reading it and I can't
remember exactly which one it was but I
was like wow like I'm gonna ask this guy
to come out here then you came out you
started working on the inverted World
stuff then you ended up profiling among
a bunch of other things like the stuff
from Tales from the inverted world and
the South was amazing and then profiling
yay was was amazing and then the Kerry
Lake story I think in my opinions the
best thing I've read from you yet that
was really awesome to read thanks so my
attitude is
we need you to write more stuff like
that and then we need to figure out how
to just get everybody to read it so they
can understand why everybody likes it so
much yeah uh the best response and you
guys sharing it is the best is like
hearing from people who don't read ever
and enjoyed reading like I couldn't yeah
like that's incredible like I couldn't
stop reading this is amazing I just feel
like you're so needed right now I don't
know I look at like what comes out of
conservative Inc and it's okay like I
know people do their thing it's so dry
and I feel like you're you just have a
Vibe I appreciate it does that make
sense it's young it's fresh it's
artistic but it's a Vibe and I don't I'm
not saying that you're intentionally
trying to be in conservative Inc yeah
um but I'm saying
just anything that doesn't fit in one
side happens to just be thrown I just it
gives me life Tim Cass is like one of
the only places hiring him because I
wouldn't have known about it oh for sure
Tim cast is like one of the only places
where you could write stuff like that
these days so I'm grateful I mean the
the yay stuff's funny because like
everyone in the world is writing one
specific thing about yay and then
Shane's like I want to go profile and
just like talk to him and and get a
better like a more full perspective and
we're like okay all right it's up to you
man you'll do it that's why I want to be
on the farm that's that's the place to
be find the real you you know
that's not a threat no I think I'm
really chill on the phone yeah I think
seeing people outside and I love doing
stuff like this but seeing people
outside of the cameras is just a
different angle right on yeah all right
man we also got Serge hey yeah been a
pleasure I love the work too Shane thank
you Eliza for everything you've been
doing especially in this whole uh I
don't know what I call it like a a
situation in the world but I appreciate
it as well uh it's been a good one I'm
at surge.com follow me on Twitter I
guess I'm on there uh yeah it was a good
one thanks thanks for hanging out
everybody we will see you all Monday or
check out any of our stuff over the
weekend we're gonna have clips that are
gonna be live so thanks for being
members at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time cheers guys